YOU ARE A SENATOR FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA PLEASE MAKE YOUR
WAY TO THE SENATE CHAMBERS
.
MEMBERS THE SENATE WILL CONVENE
IN THIRTY SECONDS. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES.
FOR JUST BRADFORD CAPPIELLO
CHIANG DALLY DODD DURAZO
GALGIANI GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE
HERTZBERG HILL HUESO TADO
JACKSON JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE
MITCHELL MONNING MORE LOCK.
MORRELL NIELSEN PAN PORTANTINO
ROTH RUBIO SKINNER STERN STONE
NUMBER WHAT COUNTY WINNER WILK.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WILL BE LEAD IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY OUR
CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING A WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. BY
SENATOR HILL. SO LET US BRING
OUR MINDS BODIES AND SPIRITS
INTO THE PRESENT MOMENT. WE
PRAY TODAY WITH THANKS FOR ALL
YOU DO TO CHANGE THE WORLD FOR
THE BETTER. SO THIS IS THE
WORLD HAS CHANGED BY ALICE
WALKER. THE WORLD HAS CHANGED
WAKE UP AND SMELL THE
POSSIBILITY. THE WORLD HAS
CHANGED. IT DID NOT CHANGE WITH
US YOUR PRAYERS WITHOUT YOUR
FACE. WITHOUT YOUR
DETERMINATION TO BELIEVE AND
LIBERATION AND KINDNESS. WITH
THE HOUSE YOU'RE DANCING
THROUGH THE YEARS THAT HAD NO
BEAT. THE WORLD HAS CHANGED. IT
DID NOT CHANGE WITH US YOUR
NUMBERS YOUR FEARS LOVE OF SELF
AND BECAUSE MOST. IT DID NOT
CHANGE WITH US YOUR STRING. THE
WORLD HAS CHANGED WAKE UP. GIVE
YOURSELF THE GIFT OF A NEW DAY.
THE WORLD HAS CHANGED. THIS
THIS DOES NOT MEAN YOU'RE WERE
NEVER HURTS. THE WORLD HAS
CHANGED RISE RISE YES AND SHINE.
RESIST THE SIREN CALL OF
DISBELIEF. THE WORLD HAS
CHANGED DON'T LET YOURSELF
REMAIN ASLEEP TO US. SO
GRACIOUS GOD OF GROWTH AND
CHANGE WE THANK YOU FOR THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF OUR
LEGISLATURE. AND FOR THEIR ON
GOING COMMITMENT TO PURSUING
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL A
MAN. OUR FLAG I. YEAH AS SOON.
GEN. INDIVISIBLE WITH REJECTION
FROM. MEMBERS WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ MOVING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE
TWENTY NINE TEN THE FOLLOWING
BILLS ARE REFERRED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN. SB
TWO EIGHTY SIX. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION MEASURES REPORTED
FROM COMMITTEE WILL BE GIVEN
THEIR SECOND READING UPON BEING
REPORTED AND ORDERED TO THIRD
READING. MEMBERS AS WE BEGIN
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
A LITTLE HOUSEKEEPING WE WILL
BREAK AT NOON TODAY FOR LUNCH
AND FOR COMMITTEES TO MEET.
SECOND READING FILE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR SIXTY FIVE. ONE
EIGHTY ONE TWELVE NINETY AND
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE NINETY
NINE THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY
THE SECOND READING FILE WILL BE
DEEMED READ MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO OTHER FINISH BUSINESS
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX SENATOR HUESO
ARE YOU PREPARED TO PRESENT
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX. HELLO
FROM RARELY WE ARE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SENATOR
GOLF GALGIANI IS READ MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FIVE THIRTY BY SENATOR
GALGIANI AN ACT RELATING TO
IMPLEMENT. SENATE GALGIANI HE
SAYS THE BY THE TIME FRAME FOR
PREVENTION CHAIN PLEASE ARRIVE.
WELL DONE SENATOR GALGIANI YOU
ARE SETTING THE TONE FOR THE
DAY. MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. PART TWO
BY OUR TO THAT HI ATKINS FIVE
BATES NOBEL BY PORGES. BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO BY CHANGE JELLY
DODD. BY DORADO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. BY GONZALEZ I GROW NO
HERTZBERG. HI HILL AYE HUESO HI
TADO. I'M IN JACKSON I JONES
LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
HI MONEY BY MORE LOCK. MORALE
NO. NIELSEN NO PAN. HI
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH I RUBIO.
SKINNER STERN. BY STONE NO
BURKE. BOB CASKEY BY WINNER BY
WILK. SENATOR MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS WE ARE PLACING MET
ITEMS ON CALL WHO WILL GO
THROUGH THE ROLE ONE TIME FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SENATOR
PORTANTINO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FIVE
THIRTY TWO BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO AAK RELATING TO
REDEVELOPMENT CENTER PORTANTINO
THANK YOU MADAM. PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS SB FIVE THIRTY TWOS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE WOULD
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW THE CITY OF GLENDALE
TO BUILD FOUR HUNDRED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
PORTANTINO MEMBERS DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BATES HI
BILL I PORGES. BRADFORD I COME
A YELLOW. I CHIANG HI DALY DODD.
I DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO I
TADO. I JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA
I'M ACQUIRE. HI MITCHELL. HI
MONNING I'M MORE LUCK MORRELL.
NIELSEN HI PAN. BY PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO. SKINNER.
STERN AYE STONE I AMBERG I
WOULD COUNTY I WIENER AYE WILK.
BY SENATOR MOVES THE CALL
MOVING TO FOLLOW NUMBER NINE
SENATOR HILL IS READY MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SAID
ABOUT FIVE THIRTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR HILL AN ACT RELATING TO
WORKERS COMPENSATION SENATOR
HILL THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS REMOVED OPPOSITION
EAST IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES
AND CLARIFY THE DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENT IN THE BILL I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENT
AND ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU CENTER HILL MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. BY
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
HI BILL. GORGEOUS HI BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO I CHIANG BY DAILY
DODD HI DORADO. I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ BY GROVE HI
HERTZBERG AYE HILL. WITH SO. HI.
HILL HI FI TADO BY JACKSON.
JONES. LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. BY MONEY BY MORE LOCK
I'M REAL. I NIELSEN I PAN HI
PORTANTINO I ROTH HI RUBIO.
SKINNER STERN. AYE STONE AYE
AMBERG IRA CASSIE BY WIENER HI
WILK HI SENATOR MOVES A CALL
MOVINGTO FILE ITEM TEN SENATOR
RUBIO. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT BY CENTER RUBIO AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES AND CLAIMED THERE'S
THROUGHOUT THE TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY SENATOR RUBIO THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT A MEMBERS
TODAY I PRESENT SB FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT WHICH IS COMING BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL ADDRESSES
A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS OF OUR
YOUTH AND THEIR CONSUMPTION OF
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES. THIS
BILL WILL HELP PARENTS AND
EDUCATORS TO IDENTIFY THESE
DEVICES TO REDUCE THEIR USE BY
STUDENTS AND JUST LAST NIGHT I
HEARD SOME REPORTS THAT ARE
SOME LUNG CANCER HAS BEEN
ASSOCIATED WITH THE E.
CIGARETTE SO WE NEED TO KEEP AN
EYE WATCH ON THAT. ARE ONCE
AGAIN THIS IS IMPORTANT TO OUR
YOUTH TO OUR COMMUNITY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BOTH THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS
AYE BATES HI BILL HI BURGESS.
EFFORT I CABALLERO I CHIANG I
DALY DODD I DORADO AYE GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
I HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE TADO I JACKSON BY JONES. HI
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING. HI MORE LOCK. I AM
RAIL. HI NIELSEN. HI PAN I
CONTINUE AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE
SKINNER HI STERN AYE STONE HI
NUMBER OUR KELSEY BY WINNER BY
WILK HI. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE UPS A MEMBER.
DALLY. DALY AYE. MEMBERS WE
HAVE A FULL HOUSE NOW AYE AYES
FORTY NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN SENATOR JACKSON'S. PANTS
TEMPORARILY MOVING TO FILE ITEM
TWELVE SENATOR UMBERG. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SAID
ABOUT FIVE SEVENTY SIX BY
SENATOR UMBERG AN ACT RELATING
TO COSTA RESOURCES CENTER BURKE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT IN
MEMBERS SB FIVE SEVENTY SIX
CONCERNS COASTAL ROSEN AND THE
BASICALLY COLLECTION OF DATA
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS SIMPLY HELP
COORDINATE THE PROS PROGRAM
WITH EXISTING STATE IN THE-
BIBLE. THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BILL. GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD HI KELLY GUERO I
CHIANG BY DAILY. DODD. HI
DORADO HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG
I HILL AYE HUESO. TADO BY
JACKSON. HI JONES. NO LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK. MORALE
NO NIELSEN. NO PAN HI
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE.
NOVEMBER HI IRA CASSIE HI
WINNER HI WILK. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BELL BY FORGES.
BY DALLY GROWTH. WITH SO I.
MORE LOCKED. WILK. WILK AYE
GROVE NO. I CITY THREE KNOWS
FIVE THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN WE NEED TO FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN SENATOR
PORTANTINO. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL SIX
TWENTY BY SENATOR PORTANTINO AN
ACT RELATING TO CRIMINAL
OFFENDER RECORD INFORMATION
CENTER PORTANTINO. THANK YOU
AYE MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB
SIX TWENTY IS BACK ON CONCERNS
RECENT AMENDMENTS REPRESENT AN
EFFORT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
TO PROVIDE THE CDC ARE SOME
FLEXIBILITY WHEN IT COMES
IMPLEMENTING THE BILL HELP
REDUCES THE COST AND MAKES IT
MORE LOGISTICALLY FEASIBLE
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS ADDRESS
PROBATION CONCERNS AND ALLOW
THEM TO BE MORE COOPERATIVE
PART OF THE FOR. THE REFERRAL
PROCESS WITH THESE AMENDMENTS
PROBATION HAS DROPPED THEIR
OPPOSITION AND IS NOW THERE'S
NOW NO OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
THIS BILL HAS PROVEN OR THIS.
METHOD IN THIS BILL IS PROVEN
TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO MEMBERS DISCUSSION%
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
I BILL BY PORGES BY BRADFORD
AYE CABALLERO AYE CHIANG I DALY.
I DODD I DORADO HI GALGIANI. I
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO BY
TADO AYE JACKSON AYE JONES BY
LEYVA I'M- AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING BY MORE LOCK. WELL HI
NIELSEN AYE PAN BY PORTANTINO.
HI ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG
IOWA KELSEY HI WIENER AYE WILK
BY. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MORE LOCK HI. SIZE
FORTY KNOWS ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN SENATOR DRAWS SO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY TWO BY
SENATOR ALSO AN ACT RELATING TO
CIVIL DETENTION FACILITIES
SENATOR ALSO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SB SIX TWO TWO IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS PROVIDE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE MAY
ASSUME JURISDICTION OVER THE
INVESTIGATION OF A DEATH OF AN
INDIVIDUAL. THAT OCCURS WITHIN
NINETY DAYS OF THE INDIVIDUALS
RELEASE FROM A CIVIL DETENTION
FACILITY WITHIN THE STATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THE CYLINDERS WERE ALSO MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING
AND HEARING THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA. I ATKINS. I
BATES. HI BILL. BY BURGESS NO.
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I CHIANG
I DALY NO DODD I DORADO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG. I
HILL AYE HUESO HI TADO AYE
JACKSON AYE JONES. LEYVA HI BY
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL YE
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN. PAN HI PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN I STONE NO BURKE OUR
CASSIE. HI WINNER BY WILK HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BATES I DON'T KNOW. GROWTH NO.
JONES NO NIELSEN NO. I CITY ONE
KNOWS NINE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN SENATOR MITCHELL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL SIX THIRTY NUMBER SENATOR
MITCHELL AN ACT RELATED TO
HEALING ARTS SENATOR MITCHELL
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
I'D LIKE TO START ON BEHAF OF
MY SEAT MATE NIGH IN THANKING
SENATOR BAIL FOR THAT AMAZING
TREAT OF. FLEET YESTERDAY WE
THANK YOU SENATOR BAIL. WHILE
THIRD PARTY FINANCING MAY BE
BENEFICIAL IN PATIENTS NEED
SERVICES THAT THEY CANNOT
IMMEDIATELY PAY THIS BILL
SENATE BILL SIX THREE NINE IS
ESSENTIAL TO PROTECT CONSUMERS.
AMONG THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE ASSEMBLY OF LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT THE BILL NO LONGER
BANDS DEFERRED INTEREST OUT
RIGHT. INSTEAD PEOPLE SIGN UP
FOR DEFERRED INTEREST MUST SIGN
UP DIRECTLY WITH THE FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION. SO THAT IT'S CLEAR
THAT THEY ARE NOT SIGNING UP
FOR A PROVIDER PAYMENT PLAN AND
THAT THE TERMS OF THE PRODUCT
ARE CLEAR AND UNDERSTOOD.
THAT'S WHY THE FOCUS OF THIS
GOAL THE OF THIS BILL IS
CONSUMER PROTECTION. PROVIDERS
AREN'T FINANCIAL EXPERTS BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY PATIENCE
COMPLETELY TRUST THEM. OTHER
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CLARIFY THAT
MEDICAL PROVIDERS CAN INFORM
PATIENTS ABOUT PAYMENT OPTIONS
THEY JUST CAN'T SIGN PEOPLE UP
DIRECTLY. THEY MUST GIVE
PATIENTS THE OPTION TO REVIEW
FINANCIAL DOCUMENTS OUTSIDE OF
THE TREATMENT AREA. THEY CAN
ONLY CHARGE PATIENTS FOR
SERVICES THAT WILL BE RENDERED
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS IF THE
PROVIDER IS USING A THIRD PARTY
CREDIT OR LOANS TO PAY FOR
SERVICES THE EXAMPLE FOR THAT
COLLEAGUES IS IF YOU GO IN AND
YOU NEED A ROOT CANAL YOU'RE
HAVING AN- IMPLANTED IT MAY
TAKE. MULTIPLE APPOINTMENTS
OVER THE SPAN OF NINE MONTHS OR
A YEAR THEY CAN'T CHARGE YOU
FOR THE FULL SERVICES BEYOND
THIRTY DAYS COULD YOU MIGHT NOT
RETURN. AND COMPLETE THE ENTIRE
TREATMENT PLAN. THEY MAY STILL
OFFER PATIENTS CREDIT CARDS
PERIOD. THEY ARE PROHIBITED
FROM PRE FILLING APPLICATIONS
ON BEHALF OF THE PATIENT. AND
WE DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION UNTIL
JULY TWENTY TWENTY AGAIN ALL
EFFORTS TO PROTECT CONSUMERS.
AND STILL ALLOW THEM TO HAVE
ACCESS TO MEDICAL CREDIT WHEN
THEY NEEDED TO PAY FOR
NECESSARY MEDICAL SERVICES
PRIMARILY DENTAL SERVICES WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA.
BY ATKINS AYE BATES. NOBEL I
BURGESS. BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO
AYE CHIANG. DALY DODD HI.
TORONTO BY GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. NO
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO AYE
TITLE I JACKSON. I JONES NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL
AYE MONNING I'M MORE LARK.
MORRELL NO NIELSEN NO PAN HI
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
NO BURKE OUR COUNTY I WINNER BY
WILK BY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. YES CHIANG HI DOLLY
MORE LOCK. I THIRTY ONE NO SIX
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM SIXTEEN
SENATOR GLAZER MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SIX
FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR GLAZER AN
ACT RELATING TO TENDENCY CENTER
GLAZER GOOD MORNING MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS THIS
MEASURES BACK FROM THE ASSEMBLY
FOR CONCURRENCY PROVIDES RENTAL
RELIEF TO ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE
MEMBERS. BASED IN CALIFORNIA BY
REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF SECURITY
DEPOSIT SERVICE MEMBERS ARE
REQUIRED TO PAY TO MOVE INTO A
RENTAL UNIT. ASSEMBLY IN THEM
AND SIMPLY AT CO AUTHORS OF THE
BILL THREE C. BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY. THANK
YOU CENTER GLAZER MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MEMBERS IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE AYE AYES FORTY NO
ZERO THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN SENATOR BRADFORD
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN OH FOUR BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AN ACT
RELATING TO TELECOMMUNICATIONS
CENTER BRADFORD THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SB SEVEN OH FOUR
MAKES IMPROVEMENTS TO A BADLY
NEEDED PROGRAM THE LIFELINE
PROGRAM THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
MAKE AND ROMAN PARTICIPATION
EASIER FOR THOSE CONSUMERS WHO
BATTLING A DISSERVICE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOUCENTER BRADFORD
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA. I
ATKINS AYE BATES. L. I. PORGES.
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE TING
AYE DALY AYE DODD AYE DORADO BY
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER BY GONZALEZ
I GROW. HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE
HUESO BY TADO I JACKSON BY
JONES NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE BY
MITCHELL AYE MONNING BY MORE
LOCK. RAIL NO NIELSEN NO PAN HI
PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER. CASSIE AYE WIENER AYE
WILK HI. THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BATES I GORGEOUS NO GROWTH. NO
MORE LOCK NO. FIVE THIRTY THREE
NO SEVEN THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN SENATOR
RUBIO MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR RUBIO AN ACT
RELATING TO HOMELESSNESS CENTER
RUBIO. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF
THE SENATE TODAY I PRESENT SB
SIX EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH IS
COMING BACK FOR CONCURRENCE IT
RECEIVED AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF NEW APPOINTEES TO THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCIAL COUNSEL TO JUST ONE
REPRESENTATIVE. OF THE STATE
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM
SB SIX EIGHTY SEVEN PASSED OUT
OF THE ASSEMBLY WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IDOL THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR RUBIO MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA. ATKINS AYE
BATES. HI BILL I PURCHASE BY
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
CHIANG I DALY. DODD THE DELI NO
DODD AYE DRAWS A I GALGIANI.
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO. HI
TADO. HI JACKSON HI JONES BY
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL
HI MONEY BY MORE LOCK TIME REAL
BY NELSON. I PAN. DO YOU KNOW I
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER. I
STERN AYE STONE. HI NUMBER. IRA
CASKEY BY WINNER BY WILK HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA HI. GALGIANI. BY
GROWTH HI EYES THIRTY NINE
KNOWS ONE THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
ARE CONCURRED IN. I HAVE BEEN
INFORMED THAT IS QUITE LOUD AT
THE BACK OF CHAMBERS SO IF
YOU'RE OFF SIDE OUTSIDE THE
FLOOR PLEASE BE A LITTLE
QUIETER IT'S A LITTLE HARD FOR
ON MISTER SECRETARY HERE FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN SENATOR
PORTANTINO. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL SIX
NINETY FIVE A SENATOR
PORTANTINO AN ACT RELATING TO
SPECIAL EDUCATION. CENTER
PORTANTINO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB SIX NINETY
FIVE IS OBVIOUSLY BACK ON
CONCURRENCE IN A REQUIRES LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES TO PROVIDE A
STUDENT'S PARENT WITH A COPY OF
COMPLETED INDIVIDUAL EDUCATION
PLANS FOR THE EIGHT MOST
COMMONLY SPOKEN LANGUAGE ISN'T
IN THAT DISTRICT. WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS OF BEING REQUESTED IMAGINE
YOU'RE A PARENT OF A SPECIAL
NEEDS CHILD AND YOU DON'T SPEAK
ENGLISH AND YOU GET THIS
DOCUMENT IN THE MAIL DETAILING
HOW YOUR CHILDREN CANRECEIVE
HELP BUT YOU CAN'T READ IT IT'S
HARD ENOUGH TO NAVIGATE THE
SYSTEM WHEN YOU. SPEAK ENGLISH
AND THE DOCUMENTARIAN WISH IT'S
A COMPLICATED SYSTEM AND WE
SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT OUR
PARENTS OF MULTI ETHNIC
BACKGROUNDS WHO DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE A COMMAND OF
THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HELP THEIR SPECIAL
NEEDS CHILDREN AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
PORTANTINO MEMBERS DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS AYE BATES
BELL BY BURGESS BRADFORD I
COVER EURO I CHIANG I DALY.
DODD AYE TERRAZZO. I GALGIANI
HI GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
NO HERTZBERG BY HILL AYE HUESO.
I TADO I JACKSON BY JONES. NO
LEYVA BY MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. I
MONEY I'M MORE LOCK MORALE.
NOPE NIELSEN NO PAN HI
PORTANTINO. HI I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
NO BURKE OUR CASKEY I WIENER.
BY WILK. HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BATES NO.
PURCHASE DELHI. MORE LUCK. ICE
THIRTY ONE NO SIX ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN MOVING
TO FILE ITEM TWENTY SENATOR
MCGUIRE ARE YOU PREPARED TO
TAKE UP. WHICH SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SAID ABOUT FIVE SIXTY BY
SENATOR REQUIRE AN ACT RELATING
TO COMMUNICATIONS. SENATOR
REQUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MADAM PRESIDENT SB FIVE SIXTY
WOULD CLARIFY THE CRITICAL.
RECEIVE PRIOR NOTIFICATION
PRIOR TO DE ENERGIZING EVENTS
AND MORE GRANULAR LEVEL. PINE
BE NOTIFYING THEM PLAYING DEAR
GUYS INVENTS WIRELESS PROVIDERS
WOULD COORDINATE WITH
APPROPRIATE STAKEHOLDERS IN
PLANNING THE MAINTAINING
CRITICAL COMMUNICATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL AS
ELECTRICAL PROVIDERS ACROSS THE
STATE DURING THE ENERGIZED AND
EVENTS SB FIVE SIX TO ENSURE
THAT OUR STATE LOCAL MARTY
VISUALS AND FIRST RESPONDERS AT
THE CRUCIAL INFORMATION THEY
NEED TO RESPOND TO THESE
EVENTS. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I'VE- THANK YOU SENATOR
REQUIRE MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SENATOR JACKSON IS
THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM HEALDSBURG
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD BUT
THIS IS JUST THE FIRST STEP. AS
WE SEE FIRE SEASONS GOING ON
OVER LONGER PERIODS OF TIME AND
THE THREADS THEIR THREATS AND
THEN THE- OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
UTILITY COMPANIES TO DE
ENERGIZED WILL LIKELY CREATE
LOTS OF UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
TO OUR ECONOMY. TO OUR OF
BUSINESSES THAT. NEED DAD
ELECTRICITY TO OUR OWN SYSTEMS
WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO SEE IT
ELECTRICAL PRODUCTION REDUCED
TURNED OFF ON SPENT THIS IS A
VERY VERY SIGNIFICANT. ASPECT
OF HOW WE ARE GOING TO BOTH
HOLISTICALLY AND EFFECTIVELY
DEAL WITH THE FIRE PROBLEM THE
ANSWERS IN CHAU SHUTTING OFF
THE ELECTRICITY IS I KNOW THE
AUTHOR IS WELL AWARE BUT THIS
IS A CRITICAL FIRST STEP TO
GETTING THIS DISCUSSION GOING.
SO THAT WE CAN CONSIDER ALL OF
THE CONSEQUENCES ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS EFFORT AND WITH THAT
I WOULD URGE AND I VOTE. THANK
YOU CENTER JACKSON MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
BEFORE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
WITH. RESPECT LASSEN AYE VOTE
ON THIS CRITICAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE EYES FORTY KNOWS ZERO THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE SENATOR
SKINNER MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SAID ABOUT FORTY NUMBER
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT RELATING
TO ENERGY. SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SB FORTY NINE IS BACK
FROM CONCURRENCE IT HELPS US DO
BETTER DEMAND RESPONSE AND
DEMAND MANAGEMENT WITH OUR
ELECTRICITY THE AMENDMENTS IN
THE ASSEMBLY ALLOWED FOR WATER
ENERGY USE TO ALSO BE
CONSIDERED. IN DEMAND RESPONSE
EFFORTS THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THE USER ENTERS KINNER MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE
SENATOR DOLLY. EVEN PRESENT
MEMBERS I. MISSED IN AND I
DIDN'T GET TO SEE THIS BILL IS
MY FIRST TIME SEEING I READ IT
THIS MORNING AND. WE HAD A
PRETTY GOOD DEBATE ON THE- HE
SEES. REGULATION TO ADD SOLAR
TO HOMES IN THAT CAME OUT OF
THEM IN THE AND WE GAVE THEM
THE POWER TO DO THAT IN THE WAY
I READ THIS BILL IS WE'RE GOING
TO GIVE THE POWER OF THE CC
ENTITY DEBBIE ARE TO. HAVE
REGULATING POWER WE'RE GONNA
ADD FIVE OR FIVE OR SO POSITION
IS THE WAY I READ IT WHICH IS
COSTLY. AND ALSO. THEY'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO FIND INDIVIDUAL
PRODUCERS IN IN THAT WITH YOU
HAVE YOU ARE. SO I THINK WE'RE
WE'RE ALLOWING. GIVING UP A LOT
OF POWER OF OUR AUTHORITY IN.
IN GIVING THE C. C. AND THE W.
R. REGULATORY POWERS WITHOUT
COMING BACK TO THIS BODY. SO
FOR THOSE REASONS I STAND IN
OPPOSITION OF A THIS BILL OF
THE WAY I READ IT I THINK WE'RE
WE'RE GIVING TOO MUCH
DISCRETION TO THESE
BUREAUCRACIES. AND THEN NOW WE
HAVE TO PAY THE PRICE AND WE
TALKED ABOUT. THE LEGISLATION
FOR ROOFTOP SOLAR IN MANY AREAS
OF THE STATE. WE HAVE PLENTY OF
SOLAR WE DON'T NEED ANYMORE
WE'RE REGULATING THAT IN THIS
CASE WE MAY BE DOING THE SAME
THING ON THESE EFFICIENCY
PROGRAMS. WHERE WE COULD SPEND
THAT MONEY MORE WISELY TO
REDUCE. OUR CARBON FOOTPRINT.
AND FOR EXAMPLE WE COULD BE
DOING MORE IN THE FORESTRY TO
REDUCE OUR CARBON. THEN FORCING
IT ON TRANSPORTATION SO THOSE
ARE THE KIND OF TAKE
DISCUSSIONS I THINK WE SHOULD
HAVE AT THIS LEVEL AND NOT
ALLOW THE PURE BUREAUCRATS TO
MAKE THOSE DETERMINATIONS
WITHOUT OUR INPUT SORRY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I. BUT
HEARD OF. NO VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER DOLLY ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE. THURS CAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AND
THANK YOU. THE BILL DOES NOT
GIVE THE DEPARTMENT OF RIDE D.
W. R. ANY AUTHORITY. ANY
ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY. AND IT
DOES NOT GIVE THEM FINING OF
FOUR THIRTY. THIRTY IN ACCURATE
READ OF THE BILL. ADDITIONALLY
THE BILL IS NOT ABOUT ENERGY
EFFICIENCY. IT'S ABOUT QUOTE
UNQUOTE SMART APPLIANCES WHICH
ARE THE TYPE OF APPLIANCES THAT
FOR EXAMPLE YOU IT I COULD
CONTROL. VIA OUR TELEPHONES AND
ALREADY OUR STATE HAS WHAT'S
CALLED TIME OF USE RATES. SO
THOSE OF US WHO DON'T REALIZE
THAT WHEN OUR APPLIANCES ARE
RUNNING DURING THE HIGHEST
PRICE RATES. AND IF WITHOUT
KNOWING THAT THEN OUR BILLS ARE
HIGHER. THAN THEY NEED TO BE
AND WITH SMART APPLIANCES AND
ARE THE PHONES RIGHT HERE WE
COULD AFFECT THAT AND THUS
LOWER OUR BILLS AND THAT'S
REALLY THE ENTIRE. OBJECTIVE
BEHIND THIS BILL AND WITH THAT
I ASK YOUR FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
AND AGAIN THERE IS POSITION.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. NO BILL BY BURGESS
NO BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
CHAIN I DALY NO DODD AYE DORADO
AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL BY WITH SO. BY TITLE I
JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. BY STERN AYE STONE.
NO BURKE IOWA CASKEY. BY WINNER
HI WILK HI PLEASE CALL THE UPS
A MEMBER. GROWTH GROVE NO. I
THIRTY ONE KNOWS NINE THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO SENATOR
PORTANTINO. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SAID ABOUT ONE
SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO AN ACT RELATING TO
FIREARMS CENTER PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING SP ONE
SEVENTY TWO ON FIRE ARMS
STORAGE BOTH IN HOMES AND IN
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES IT
IS BACK ON CONCURRENT WITH
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS AND
CHAPTER AMENDMENTS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO MEMBERS DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCH
ELEVENTH BY ATKINS. AYE BATES
NOBEL. I PURCHASE. NO BRADFORD
AYE CABALLERO CHIANG NO DALY NO
DODD. HI THERE ALSO BY GALGIANI
I GLAZER BY GONZALEZ I GROWTH
NO HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
HI TADO. JACKSON HI JONES NO
EYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING BY MORE
LARK MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO PAN
AYE PORTANTINO I ROTH. RUBIO I
SKINNER. BY STERN HI STONE NO
BURKE IRA CASKEY I WIENER AYE
WILK NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS COVER GYRO NO TADO.
MORE LOCK NO ROTH. FIVE THREE
SIX KNOWS TWELVE THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEM TWENTY THREE SENATOR ALLEN
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FORTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR ALLEN AND ACT REALLY
INTO ELECTIONS. ALAN MEMBERS SB
FORTY SEVEN REQUIRES SIGNATURE
GATHERS TO PROVIDE CALIFORNIA
VOTERS WITH THE NAMES OF THE
TOP THREE FUNDERS OF AN
INITIATIVE CAMPAIGN AT A MOMENT
WHEN THAT DISCLOSURE IS CRUCIAL
WHEN A PETITION IS BEING
SHARED. WITH THOSE VOTERS IN
THERE DECIDING WHETHER NOT TO
SCIENCE. ASSIGNMENTS WERE NON
SUBSTANTIVE IN THE ADDED CO
AUTHORS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALLEN MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. AYE BATES.
NO BELL. I PURCHASE BY BRADFORD
HI KELLY HERO BY CHIANG BY
DELHI. NO DODD I DORADO I
GALGIANI. HI GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH. HERTZBERG
BY. HILL BY WITH SO. HI TADO I
JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA BY
MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL. HI MONNING
BY MORE LOCK MORRELL. NO
NIELSEN NO PAN. HI PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE. NO BURKE
OUR CASKEY OUR WINNER BY WILK
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS GROVE. NO MORE LOOK NO.
I CITY TO KNOWS EIGHTY ASSEMBLY
MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN MOVING
TO FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE
SENATOR MCGUIRE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. IN ABOUT
TWO SIXTY TWO BY SENATOR
REQUIRE AN ACT RELATING TO
MARINE RESOURCE CENTER MCGUIRE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
LIKE FISH YOU'RE GONNA LIKE
THIS BILL. AMENDMENTS TAKING
THE ASSEMBLY PROVIDE GUIDANCE
ON THE CONFUSING PROCESS FOR
NEW AQUACULTURE PERMITS IN
AQUACULTURE PERMIT RENEWALS
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION AND ALSO UPDATE THE
VESSEL PERMIT PROCESS FOR
SALMON CRAB FISHING BOATS WHICH
I KNOW THE- MAN PRESIDENT IS
ESPECIALLY INTERESTED IN WITH
RESPECT LASSEN AYE VOTE ON SB
TWO SIXTY TWO ON THE MINUTES.
THANK YOU SENATOR REQUIRE
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARE TO THAT
AND I ATKINS AYE BATES. BELL HI
BURGESS. HI BRADFORD BY CARRIER.
I CHIANG. I DALY AYE DODD HI
DRAWS SO. I GALGIANI. HI GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW BY
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI TODDLE. I JACKSON. I JONES
NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. HI
MITCHELL. BY MONEY I'M MORE
LOCK. MORRELL NO NIELSEN. PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. I
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN. BY
STONE. NO I'M BURKE OUR CASKEY
I WINNER BY WILK HI. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS STONE
NOTIFY. BATES. BY MORE LOCK. HI
NIELSEN. NIELSEN I. I THIRTY
EIGHT KNOWS TO THE ASSEMBLY
MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN MOVING
TO FILE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT
SENATOR ALAN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. THE BILL TO NINETY
SIX BY SENATOR ALLEN AN ACT
RELATING TO STUDENT FINANCIAL
AID. SENATOR ALAN. MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS ABOUT
BILLS NOW BACK IN CONCURRENCE
IT EXTENDS ELIGIBILITY FOR THE
CAL GRANT TO ASYLUM APPLICANTS
WHO POSSESS A VALID EMPLOYMENT
AUTHORIZATION DOCUMENT AND A
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER MINUTES
THE BILL ADD A CO AUTHOR THE
AVOID CHAPTER NOW THANKS TO
IRWIN NOVACK THE BILL HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FROM
BOTH HOUSES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NAY VOTE THANK YOU
CENTER ALLEN MEMBERS DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. BY
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
BELL BY BURGESS. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CHIANG. DELHI DODD.
I DORADO I GALGIANI. GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROW. HI HERTZBERG I
HILL. HI FI HUESO BY TADO I
JACKSON. HI JONES. BY LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL HI MONEY
I'M MORE LOCK MORALE NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH.
I RUBIO I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE NO BURKE ABA CASKEY I
WINNER HI WILK BY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES NO
PURCHASE NO. CHIANG BY DAILY NO.
GALGIANI BY MORE LOCK. BY
THIRTY THREE NO SIX THE
ASSEMBLY MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
NINE SENATOR MCGUIRE WHILE
YOU'RE OVER THERE NOW KEEPING
ME ON MY TOES MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SAID ABOUT THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
REQUIRE AN ACT RELATING TO
JUVENILES SENATOR MCGUIRE MANY
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
NEED TO BE A TO GET YOU A GIANT
ORANGE. JACKET SO JUST MAKING
SURE IT'S WE CAN A DODGER BLUE
ON TODAY ASSEMBLY MOMENTS
DIRECTED JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO
UPDATE THE FOSTER YOUTH
PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATION
APPROVAL FORMS AND TO PROVIDE
PROTECTIONS FOR FOSTER YOUTH
PRIVACY AND THE RIGHT TO
CONSENT TO RELEASE MEDICAL
RECORDS HE'S IN AN IMMENSE
TAKING SB THREE SEVEN SEVEN. SB
THREE SEVEN SEVEN IS NOT
SUPPORTED BY THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA. IN JUVENILE
COURT JUDGES RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN ITEM. THANK YOU SIR
MCGUIRE MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE CENTERED DOLLY. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT QUESTION
FOR THE AUTHOR. SOON REQUIRE WE
TAKE A QUESTION ALWAYS AT FROM
MY GOOD FRIEND THANK YOU SIR
SENTIMENT NOT THAT IT'S LIKE TO
KNOW WHY YOU DON'T PERCENT FROM
YOUR SEAT IS SOMETHING THAT
I'VE DONE TO YOU OR I ACTUALLY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL BUT- I
THINK HE'S ONLY. PRESENTED FROM
HIS CHAIR LIKE ONCE AND YOU
ONLY SET THE CHAIR TO TAKE THE
PHOTO SO I'M WONDERING IF
YOU'RE ALL MY FRIENDS AT THEIR
SOMETHING I SMELL OR SOME.
PLEASE LET ME KNOW. I THANK YOU
SENATOR DOLLY. UNDER MCGUIRE
SIR DOLLY NIGHT WE COMMUNICATE
QUITE OFTEN WERE BOTH WEARING
RED TIES TODAY WE TEXTED EACH
OTHER THIS MORNING. A AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY AND I AM NOT
SUPPOSED TO USE THE NAME AS
THE- SECRETARY IS ABOUT THE
THROWER PAIN. BUT IT IS NO
OFFENSE AND ABSOLUTELY LOVE THE
GOOD SENATOR AND THAT WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND I'M- HEADING OVER TO
HIM RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU
SENATOR MCGUIRE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. HI BILL HI BURGESS
HI BRADFORD HI KELLY HERO BY
CHAIN AYE DALY AYE DODD. HI
THERE ALSO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. HI
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO BY
OUR TADO. I JACKSON. JONES. HI
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
BY MONEY I'M MORE LUCK AMARILLO
I NIELSEN AYE PAN. PORTANTINO I
ROTH. I RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN.
BY STONE. BY BURKE I WERE
CASKEY AYE WIENER AYE WILK. I
AM OKAY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS JACKSON. HI. I THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM THIRTY SENATOR
SKINNER. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY FOUR BY SENATOR SKINNER
AN ACT RELATING TO CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE CENTER SKINNER. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS. SB
THREE NINETY FOURS BACK THE
AMENDMENTS TAKING THE ASSEMBLY
ONE OF THEM WAS FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO ENSURE THAT A
PERSON IS NOT PLACED IN SUCH A
DIVERSION COURT IF THE ALLEGED
CRIME WAS AGAINST THEIR
DEPENDENT ALSO THAT THE
DIVERSION COULD BE NO LONGER
THAN TWO YEARS. AND OTHER
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THIS BILL
IS COMPLETELY VOLUNTARY IT IS
ONLY IF THE COURT CHOOSES TO
ESTABLISH A DIVERSION PROGRAM
ANDBOTH THE JUDGE AND THE DA
HAVE TO AGREE IN ITS
ESTABLISHMENT. THE BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY THE AMERICAN
CONSERVATIVE UNION AMONGST MANY
OTHERS AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ENATOR SKINNER
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SENATOR JONES THANK YOU
A MAN PRESENT JUST A QUICK
QUESTION FOR CLARIFICATION FROM
THE AUTHOR PLEASE CENTER
SKINNER WE TAKE A QUESTION YES.
PLEASE READ. THE THANK YOU. IT
WASN'T CLEAR TO THE HEARINGS IN
SO I JUST WANT TO MAYBE IF YOU
CAN CLARIFY IT TODAY ON THE
BILL IS IT YOUR INTENTION TO
HAVE THE BILL BE PERMISSIVE OR
MANDATORY. PERMISSIVE NOT
MANDATORY VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTIONS. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE CENTERS CAN WE
JUDGE CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BELL I BURGESS.
BRADFORD BY CARRIER I CHIANG NO
DALY. DOT HI DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO I TADO. JACKSON
JONES. LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. HI
MITCHELL. BY MONEY I'M MORE
LOCK NO MORALE NO NIELSEN NO
PAN. HI PORTANTINO AYE ROTH BY
RUBIO I SKINNER AYE STERN I
STONE. SO NUMBER OUR CASKEY BY
WINNER HI WILK BY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BATES. NO
BURGESS. DALY GROVE NO. OUR
TADO. JACKSON HI JONES. NO. THE
PIES TWENTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM THIRTY
ONE SENATOR ARCHULETA MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY FIVE A
SENATOR ARCHULETA AN ACT
RELATING TO WILD GAME ANIMALS
SOONER CHIRLA. THANK YOU BETTER
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT SB
THREE NINETY FIVE THE WILDLIFE
TRAFFIC SAFETY ACT WHICH BACK
IS BACK FROM THE ASSEMBLY ON
CONCURRENCE AS YOU KNOW THIS
BILL ALLOWS THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION TO CREATE A WEB
BASED PORTAL. THAT WOULD ALLOW
USERS TO LOG INFORMATION
REGARDS TO LARGE GAME ANIMAL
COLLISION AND THE SAME TIME
DELIVER PERMITS FOR THE TAKE OF
THESE LARGE GAME ANIMALS.
EDMUNDS TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY
LIMIT THE GEOGRAPHICAL SIZE AND
SCOPE OF THE PROGRAM TO A
MAXIMUM OF THREE GEOGRAPHICALLY
DISPERSED SITES IDENTIFIED BY
THE APARTMENT TO BE AREAS OF
HIGH WILDLIFE VEHICLE
COLLISIONS. FURTHERMORE
AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DISPATCH AN
INJURED ANIMAL AFTER COLLISION
AND INSTEAD PASSED THE
COMMISSION TO DEVELOP A PROGRAM
THAT AUTHORIZES A LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO EUTHANIZE AN
INJURED ANIMAL. AND FINALLY IT
MEMBERS MAKE THIS ENTIRE PILOT
PROGRAM SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SENATOR HUESO. THANK YOU
MAYOR PRESIDENT WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR CARRYING THIS
BILL THIS IS AN IMPORTANT%
MEASURE WANT TO SHARE A STORY
WITH WITH ALL OF YOU REGARDING
THIS BILL AND WHY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT. NO MY GRANDFATHER
LIVED TO BE A HUNDRED AND TWO.
AND HE WORKED OUT IN YOU KNOW I
WANTED TO LEARN THE SECRET TO A
LONG LIFE FROM HIM AND I. I
INTERVIEWED HIM OFTEN AND- YOU
KNOW HE WORKED OUT IN THE IN
THE FORCE GATHERING LUMBER. AND
HE SOLD IT TO IN IN THE TOWN
DOWN TO KILEY SCHOOL. AND SO HE
SPENT OFTENTIMES A LOT OF TIME
IN THE FOREST AND- AND HE TOLD
ME THAT SOMETIMES HE WOULD
GATHER HIS OWN FOOD FROM. THE
SURROUNDING AREAS AND HE WOULD
HUNT OUT THERE. TO EAT AND I
ASKED HIM WHAT WHAT WAS THE
MOST. DELICIOUS THING YOU EVER
EIGHT THAT WAS A WILD ANIMAL HE
SAID SKUNK. I COULDN'T BELIEVE
IT SKUNK. EVERY TIME I IC
SKUNKS. YOU KNOW I THE
CURIOSITY AND ME AS P. THEN ONE
NIGHT WHEN I SEE YOU KNOW
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE PLENTY AS
CONSIDER AT THAT AWFUL PRAY N
THE ROAD SIDE I OFTEN THINK
ABOUT MY GRANDFATHER. BUT WITH
THIS BILL NOW THINK ABOUT.
CENTER ARE TO LET THEM MAYBE
WHO KNOWS. YEP THANK YOU
SENATOR HUESO SENATOR DOLLY.
EVEN PRESIDENT MEMBERS A ALSO
SUPPORT THIS BILL YOU KNOW
COMING FROM THE RULE AREA WE
HAVE A LOT OF ACTUALLY THE
NUMBER ONE TAKING UP OF DEER IS
AUTOMOBILE THEY THEY THEY WE
LOSE MORE WILDLIFE TO
AUTOMOBILES THAN WE DO TO
HUNTING OR ANY OTHER THING SO I
CALL THIS THE GRILL TO GRILL
FROM THE FRONT GRILLE YOUR CAR
TO THE GRILL OF YOUR GRILL SO.
I PERCEIVE BRING THIS FORWARD.
IT'S A IT'S NOT TO. AND IF YOU
HAD ONE IN THE GRILL OF YOUR
CAR IT CAUSES REALLY LILY
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS DAM SO YOU
MIGHT AS WELL BE ABLE TO
CONSUME SOME OF THAT FINE
TASTING MEAT AS WELL THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAUL YOU
CLEARLY GOT A GOOD NIGHT'S
SLEEP LAST NIGHT SENATOR JONES
HEY. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
NOT SURE IF THIS IS A QUESTION
OF THE ARTHUR AUTHOR OR- OUR
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY I'LL LET
YOU THE JUDICATA. BUT I THOUGHT
THIS WAS JUST TO GET A BILL
COMING BACK ON CONCURRENCE I
DIDN'T KNOW WE WERE GONNA HAVE
TO SURVIVE THROUGH A WHOLE
NOTHER PRESENTATION OF THE
BILLS SO. AT IT IF YOU HAD IN
THIS EXPLAINED RESTAURANT
OCCURRENCE OR A NEW BILL AND
THAT IS AT THE DISCRETION OF
THE AUTHOR HOW MUCH THEY CHOOSE
TO SPEAK ON A BILL THANK YOU
SENATOR JONES. MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CENTER ARCHULETA PLEASE CLOSE
WELL I WOULD LIKE TO CLARIFY A
FEW THINGS TO MY FELLOW
SENATORS. THAT FIRST OFF IF I
MAY YOU CANNOT TAKE THE GRILL
AND JUST MOVE IT. AND PUT IT ON
THE BARBECUE THAT IS AGAINST
THE RULES THAT'S NUMBER ONE
NUMBER TWO AND REFERENCE THAT
ANIMAL THAT YOU TALK ABOUT THE
SKUNK THAT IS NOT AUTHORIZED.
THAT WHEN YOUR GRANDFATHER
PROBABLY HAD A VERY TAKE A
SPECIAL TECHNIQUE HOW TO
CAPTURE AND HAVE LUNCH WITH
THAT PARTICULAR ANIMAL BUT FROM
WHAT I UNDERSTAND THE REST OF
THE STORY GOES. THERE WAS A
SKUNK IN FRONT OF HIM AND THEY
BOTH SAT DOWN TOGETHER AND THEY
HAD DINNER WITH GOD KNOWS WHAT
IT WAS BUT IT WAS IN ANOTHER
STOCK I WILL SAY THAT. AND IN
REFERENCE TO SOME OF THE OTHER
THINGS IT IS REALLY. A PLEASURE
TO STAND UP HERE BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT ALL OF YOU HAVE HEARD THE
STORIES IT'S AS WENT ON BUT
THIS WENT ACROSS THE NATION.
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT IT HAD
ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT TITLES
BUT IT REALLY IS. A BILL TO
PROTECT AND IT REALLY IS IT'S A
IT IS A PUBLIC SAFETY BILL.
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT SOME
AREAS OF THE STATE CALIFORNIA
WE DO HAVE THE PLEASURE EN EL
BURKE. HUMANS RP DANGER DID IN.
AS WELL. BY SIXTY EIGHT IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT. AND THAT
ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER ARCHULETA MEMBERS.
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. BLESS YOU
I'M SORRY IS THERE. THERE IS
NOT. AYE AYES FORTY NO ZERO THE
MID THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM THIRTY
TWO SENATOR BELL IS READY
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SAID ABOUT FORTY FIVE A SENATOR
BILL AN ACT RELATING TO DRIVING
PRIVILEGE SENATOR BELL MEMBERS
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS
BILL IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE. WE
HAVE AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY
REDUCE COSTS ADDRESS CHAPTER
IN. AND ALLEVIATE CONCERNS
REGARDING DMV'S ASSORTED TO
SUSPEND LICENSES NO OPPOSITION
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU
ELSEWHERE AND I GO. THANK YOU
CENTER BELL MEMBERS DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS. BATES.
NOBEL HI PORGES NO BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO AYE CHIANG NO DALY NO
DODD. I DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO I
TADO I JACKSON BY JONES. JONES
NO LEYVA HI MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL.
BY MONEY. I'M MORE LUCK NO MORE
REAL NO NIELSEN. PAN I
PORTANTINO BY ROTH. BY RUBIO.
BY SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
NOVEMBER IRAQ OWSKI I WIENER.
HI WILK NO. THESE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS. GROWTH
NIELSEN. ALL EYES TWENTY EIGHT
KNOWS NINE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN GOING ON TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE SENATOR
MCGUIRE WHERE WILL YOU BE
LOCATED NOW. SENATOR MCGUIRE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
THAT ABOUT FIVE TWENTY THREE BY
SENATOR REQUIRE AN ACT RELATING
TO ELECTIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE
AND SENATOR HILLS DESK THANK
YOU SO MUCH BETTER PRESIDENT
THIS IS SB FIVE TWENTY THREE
COMING BACK FROM THE ASSEMBLY
MINUTES TAKEN THEIR- PROVIDE
CLARIFICATION ON TRANSLATION
REQUIREMENTS. IN A LINE
CONFIDENTIALITY IN ACCESS RULES
FOR UNSIGNED AND MISMATCHING
SIGNATURES WITH THE LAWS THAT
GAVE THAT GOVERN AFFIDAVITS FOR
VOTER REGISTRATION RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ON ANY
AMENDMENTS. DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. AND
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GONNA GO ONE
TIME THROUGH THE ROLE AND THEN
PLACE THE ITEM ON CALL SO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. I ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES NOBEL I
BRIDGES NO BRADFORD CAPPIELLO I
CHIANG. DELHI. NO DODD AYE
DORADO I GOT JOHNNY BY GLAZER
AYE GONZALES BY GROVE. NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO I
TACO I JACKSON HI BY JONES.
LEYVA. I'M ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL
AYE MONNING. MORE LOCK NO
MORRELL. NOPE NIELSEN. NO PAN
AYE PORTANTINO BY ROTH I RUBIO
BY SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER OUR CASKEY AYE WIENER
AYE WILK NO. SENATOR MCGUIRE
MOVES TO CALL COLLEAGUES WE ARE
GOING TO GO BACK TO OF FILE
ITEM TWENTY FOUR AND THEN WILL
TAKE UP FILE ON ITEM TWENTY SIX
ON BEHALF OF OUR PRESIDING
OFFICER TODAY THIS IS A MATTER
OF BILL BY SENATOR LABOR MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL SEVENTY ONE BY SENATOR
LEYVA RELATING TO THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR SENATOR LEYVA THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT OF MEMBERS
SENATE BILL SEVENTY ONE IS BACK
FROM THE ASSEMBLY ON
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY NARROWED THE BILL'S
LANGUAGE AND ADDRESSED IT
CAPTURING OUT ISSUE. AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR JOHN THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVENTY ONE. EVEN
AS I PREFERRED THE GOOD SKINNER
FROM CHINOS ORIGINAL DRAFT.
THAT INCLUDED ALL KENNEDY
CONTROL COMMITTEES IN THIS
REGARD BUT THAT IS THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS FRANKLY WE
SHOULD PROHIBIT THE USE OF
CAMPAIGN FUNDS FOR ANY CRIMINAL
OFFENSE DEFENSE. SENATE
REPUBLICANS OF OFFERED SUCH A
MAJOR IN THE PAST BUT HAS
FAILED TO PASS THIS HOUSE. IN
ANY EVENT I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HER DILIGENT WORK ON
THE ISSUE OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
THE CAPITAL. NAY DRIVE VOTE ON
SB SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU
CENTER JONES ANY FURTHER DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION SEEING AND
HEARING ON SENATOR LABOR YOU
MAY CLOSE. ME TOO I LIKE THE
ORIGINAL VERSION BEST BUT
THAT'S OKAY WE ARE HERE TODAY
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASE MISTER SECRETARY ONE TIME
THROUGH THE ROLE PLEASE. ALLEN
HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES BY BILL I BRIDGES.
BRADFORD. CABALLERO I CHIANG BY
DAILY I DODD. HI DORADO. HI
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ OUR GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI TADO HI JACKSON HI BY JONES
HI LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL. HI MONEY BY MORLOCK
MORALE AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN. I
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH BY RUBIO I
SKINNER. SKINNER HI TURN BY
STONE I AMBERG OUR COUNTY. I
CAN SEE AYE WIENER HI WILK BY.
ALEX WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE ROLE
ONE MORE TIME FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THEN CLOSE THE ROLE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
PURCHASE. BRADFORD HI ICE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER INSOFAR CONCURRED IN
WITHIN A MOVE NOW TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY SIX SENATOR LEYVA MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SAID
ABOUT TWO SIXTY SIX BY SENATOR
LEYVA AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT SENATOR
LEYVA THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY
SIX IS BACK ON CONCURRENT
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY WERE
TECHNICAL TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING IN NATURE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM. SENATOR STONE. GOOD
MORNING MADAM PRESIDENT THIRTY
SIX HOURS TO GO. HI RISE
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB TWO SIXTY SIX THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW RIGHT HIGHER READ
TO RECEIVE AND CORRECTLY
CALCULATED PENSION BENEFITS
WERE AN ERROR RESULTS IN PAYING
THAT RETIREE HIGHER PENSION
BENEFITS AND ALLOWED BY LAW. I
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
AUTHOR IS TRYING TO DO HERE AND
QUITE FRANKLY I SHARE THE VIEW
WITH MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM
CHINO THAT PENSIONS MUST BE
CORRECTED AND CALCULATED IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE LAW. TIRED
OF STATE PUBLIC SERVANTS SHOULD
NEVER. NEVER FIND THEMSELVES ON
THE HOOK FOR OVERPAYMENTS
HOWEVER I'M GREATLY CONCERNED
SB TWO SIXTY SIX BROAD
PROVISIONS COULD QUITE EASILY
BE ABUSED AND BE DETRIMENTAL TO
PUBLIC AGENCIES AND OF COURSE
TAXPAYERS THIS BILL WILL
INCREASE COSTS TO TAXPAYERS AS
A FACT. IN A SOMETHING I DON'T
LIKE. THE COST WILL COME IN THE
FORM OF INCREASED EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTIONS TO HANDLE THE
INCREASED LIABILITY THE CALPERS
WILL BE UNDER TO REVIEW
COMPENSATION PROPOSALS. FROM MY
INTERPRETATION OF THIS MEASURE
SB TWO SIXTY SIX REPLACE 1100%
OF THE TOTAL LIABILITY BURDEN
FOR OVER PAYMENTS ON PUBLIC
AGENCIES MANY OF WHOM SPEND
OVER TWENTY THREE PERCENT. OF
THEIR BUDGETS TODAY ON PENSION
LIABILITY. AND IT DEMANDS A
LOSS OF THE CALPERS HAS NO
INCENTIVE TO EVEN PROPERLY
CALCULATE. BENEFIT PAYMENTS
WHICH IS THE SOURCE OF THE
PROBLEM TO BEGIN WITH I
COMMEND. MY FRIEND FROM CHINO
FOR TRYING TO FIX A. PROBLEM
BUT THIS BILL IS NOT THE BEST
WAY TO DO SO FOR THOSE REASONS
ARGENEAU FOREIGN SB TWO SEVENTY
TWO SIX SIX. THANK YOU CENTER
STILL FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SENATOR MORLOCK
THANK YOU BETTER PRESIDENTS.
YOU KNOW AND WE DO WORK PRODUCT
IN A CPA FIM YOU HAVE A
PREPARE AND THEN YOU HAVE
SOMEONE WHO REVIEWS THE WORK IN
ITS PRE TYPE CHECK AND THEN IT
GETS COMPLETED GOES TO A
PARTNER FOR FINAL REVIEW AND-
GOES OUT THE DOOR SO HOPEFULLY
EVERYTHING IS BEEN. DOUBLE
CHECKED BEFORE THE FINAL
PRODUCT IS DELIVERED YOU DON'T
WANT TO HAVE THE EMBARRASSMENT
OF A CLIENT COMING BACK SAYING
YOU MADE A- MISTAKE. ON MY TAX
RETURN OR MY FINANCIAL
STATEMENT. SO YOU HAVE QUALITY
CONTROLS. AND SO. I'M I'M
WONDERING. IF PERHAPS THE
ANSWER IS TO IMPROVE THE
QUALITY CONTROL PROCESS INSIDE
OUR- PENSION SYSTEMS BUT MAYBE.
THERE SHOULD BE ANOTHER LAYER
AT THAT MAYBE WE HAVE AN
INSURANCE POLICY THAT IF YOU DO
MAKE A MISTAKE IF YOU FIND OUT
LATER THAT THERE IS AN ERROR
THAT. THE INSURANCE CARRIER
WOULD PAY THE DIFFERENCE AND
NOT HAVE A SURPRISE BUDGET
EXPENSE. ON A MUNICIPALITY WHO
IS IN PART OF THE QUALITY%
CONTROL PROCESS OR MAYBE WE PUT
THEM IN THAT PROCESS SO THAT
THEY TAKE OWNERSHIP OF THE
CALCULATION OF THE BENEFITS. SO
IT'S BEEN INTERESTING TO WATCH
THIS BILL I'VE BEEN LAYING OFF
BUT I BELIEVE AT THIS POINT
THAT I SHOULD BE VOTING NO ON
SB TWO SIX SIX THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU ANY FOR
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE CENTER LEYVA
YOU MAY CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
AND COLLEAGUES WE ARE MISSING A
MEMBER SO WE WILL GO THROUGH
THE ROLE ONCE AND THEN PUT THE
MATTER ON CALL MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
NOBEL BY PURCHASE NO BRADFORD.
HI KELLY ERA. BY CHIANG I DALY
AYE DODD. TIRADO. I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER BY GONZALEZ BY
GROWTH. HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE
HUESO BY TADO. I JACKSON I
JONES NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING AYE
MOORLACH NO MORALE NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
BY RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE STERN
AYE STONE NOVEMBER I HAVE A
COUNTY BY WIENER AYE WILK HI.
PLEASE CALL THE OF THE MEMBER.
DODD BY GROWTH. BY THIRTY TWO
NO SEVEN THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IT'S OUR CONCURRED IN MEMBERS
WE HAVE THREE ITEMS THAT ARE ON
CALL SO WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL ON THOSE ITEMS WE WILL
START WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS FOR
JUST. DALY NO TADO I. JONES. BY
MORE LOCK BY RUBIO. I SKINNER
BY. FOR JUST NO. EYES THIRTY
THREE NO SEVEN SEVEN THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
IN WHEN I MOVED TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS. HI
GORGEOUS BY ALLEY. GROW FROM.
JONES NO. MORE LOCK MORRELL.
RUBIO. I SKINNER HI BY THIRTY
FIVE KNOWS ONE THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BELL
BY KELLY I JACKSON. I JONES BY
RUBIO. TRIVIA SKINNER HI HI. HI
EYES FORTY NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. GOING
TO START WITH FILE ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT. SENATOR TO RAZA WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PRESENT FILE ITEM
THIRTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING PASS ON FILE WE ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR.
SENATOR GONZALEZ WOULD YOU LIKE
PRESENT PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM
FORTY FIVE SENATOR MCGUIRE.
PASS ON FILE. FILE ITEM FORTY
SEVEN. NO SO SORRY. SPECIAL
OKAY WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO FILE
ITEM FIFTY FIVE SENATOR
ARCHULETA. PASS ON FILE FILE
ITEM FIFTY EIGHT SENATOR PAM.
YEAH HEY MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA RELATIVE TO THE
IMMIGRATION AND NATIONALITY ACT
CENTER PAN THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS A ACR ONE
FROM BY SOME MEMBER BONTA
OPPOSES THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S IMPLEMENTED
CHANGES TO IMMIGRATION POLICY
KNOWN AS PUBLIC CHARGE THAT
TARGETS ARE VIABLE COMMUNITIES
AND CAUSES HARDSHIP TO UNTOLD
NUMBERS OF IMMIGRANTS TRYING TO
REALIZE OUR OWN AMERICAN DREAM.
ON OCTOBER TENTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY PROPOSED A
NEW SET OF REGULATIONS
REGARDING PUBLIC CHARGE THE
TERMINATIONS. IN AUGUST
NINETEEN TO TWENTY NINETEEN THE
FARM HEALTH. DHS PUBLISHED ITS
FINAL RULE REGARDING PUBLIC
CHARGE WHICH EXPERIENCE A LIST
OF BENEFITS CONSIDERED WHEN
DETERMINING WHO CAN CONSTITUTES
EIGHT PUBLIC CHARGE. BEYOND
CASH ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
INCLUDE HEALTHCARE HOUSING AND
NUTRITION ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS.
PROGRAMS THAT HELP ALL PEOPLE
AND THEIR FAMILIES TO STAY
HEALTHY WORK THRIVE AND
CONTRIBUTE TO SOCIETY. THE
FINAL RULE ALSO CONSIDERS THE
AGE OF AN INDIVIDUAL BEING
UNDER EIGHTEEN AND OVER SIXTY
ONE WOULD BE CONSIDERED A
NEGATIVE. THE ABSENCE OF KERN
EMPLOYMENT OR LACK OF PROSPECT
OF EMPLOYMENT THE USE OF PUBLIC
BENEFITS L. ENGLISH PROFICIENCY
MEDICAL CONDITIONS AND INCOME
LEVEL. SO QUITE LITERALLY IF
YOU'RE TOO YOUNG. OR YOU'RE OLD
ARE YOUR SICK ARE YOUR POOR ARE
YOU DON'T SPEAK ENGLISH. IT
WILL COUNT AGAINST YOU UNDER
THE PROPOSED REGULATIONS. THESE
CHANGES HAVE REAL IMPACTS ACR
ONE OBJECTS TO THE FINAL RULES
RELATED TO PUBLIC CHARGE AND
URGES THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
RECONSIDER A ROLL BACK THESE
CHANGES. CALIFORNIA IS STRONGER
WHEN RESIDENTS IN NEED ARE ABLE
TO ACCESS THAT SAFETY NET
WITHOUT FEAR FOR THEMSELVES
THEIR FAMILIES OR THEIR FUTURES.
OUR STATE SUCCESS HAS BEEN
BUILT ON. IMMIGRANTS WHO HAVE
COME SOME OF WHO NEEDED A
LITTLE HELP PERHAPS NOW THEN
WE'VE ALL SUFFERED IN TIMES
RECESSION AND OTHER ECONOMIC
DISTRESS. AND MANY OF US ARE
FAMILIES AT CERTAIN TIMES MIGHT
HAVE NEEDED A LITTLE HELP FOR
US TO. THEN GET BACK ON HER
FEET AND THEN SUCCEED TO BECOME
THE NEXT ENTREPRENEURS THE NEXT
BUSINESS OWNERS THE NEXT GREAT
EMPLOYEES THAT INVENTS ARE
TREATING YOU PATENTS OR OTHER
TYPES OF THINGS. WHAT WE'RE NOW
TELLING EVERYONE IS THAT YOU
CAN'T ACCEPT THAT LITTLE BIT OF
HELP BECAUSE IF YOU DO. YOU
CANNOT STAY YOU ARE NOW YOU YOU
DO NOT A FUTURE HERE IN THIS
COUNTRY. THIS I THINK IS WRONG
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON ACR ONE. THANK YOU
CENTER PAN MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
MONNING. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION. THE
EXCESS OF THIS PROPOSED CHANGE
IN EXISTING IMMIGRATION LAW IS
GOING TO HAVE A DRAMATIC PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVERSE PUBLIC HEALTH
IMPACT IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
REPRESENTING A COUNTY WITH A
PUBLIC HOSPITAL THIS IS GONNA
AFFECT NOT ONLY ACCESS TO
MEDICAL SERVICES BUT ALSO
MECHANISMS MAINTAINING THE
BUDGET IN THE ECONOMY OF THAT
HOSPITAL THERE ARE CITIZEN
CHILDREN ELIGIBLE FOR NUTRITION
ASSISTANCE WHO BECAUSE OF THE
IMPACTS OF THIS ON FAMILIES.
WILL NO LONGER SECURE WHAT
THEY'RE ELIGIBLE FOR AS POOR.
US CITIZEN CHILDREN IT'S GONNA
HAVE A DRAMATIC IMPACT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES A LOT OF THE PEOPLE
WORKING IN OUR COMMUNITIES IN
AGRICULTURE IN HOSPITALITY
TOURISM DO NOT EARN ENOUGH TO
PROVIDE FOOD FOR THEIR FAMILIES
OVER THE COURSE OF A MONTH THEY
DEPEND ON NUTRITIONAL
SUPPLEMENT SUPPORT FOR THEIR
CITIZEN CHILDREN. AND THE LINES
ARE GETTING LONGER AND LONGER
IT FOOD BANKS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THIS IS A DRACONIAN
MEASURE AND I SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION THAT SEEKS TO PUT
CALIFORNIA ON RECORD URGING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
RECONSIDER. WHAT IS SET ILL
CONCEIVED. EFFORT IN THEIR
BROADER IMMIGRATION STRATEGY SO
I URGE AN AYEVOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR MONNING SEE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER PAN
YOU MAY CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BILL GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I CHIANG.
DALY DOT. HI DORADO I GALGIANI
BY GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG. HILL AYE HUESO I
TADO. I JACKSON. I JONES. NO
LEYVA TIME ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL
BY MONEY I'M MORE LOCK. MORRELL
NO NIELSEN. PAN HI PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
STERN BY STONE NOVEMBER OUR
CASKEY BY WINNER BY WILK.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS
WE'RE GONNA MOVE BACK TO FILE
ITEM FIFTY SIX SENATOR STERN
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER AN
ACT RELATING TO BUSINESS
CENTERS STERN THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE RESENT
AB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT ON
BEHALF ASSEMBLY MEN GALLAGHER
PERSONALLY I THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR WORKING CLOSELY WITH US ON
AMENDMENTS BEFORE THE FLOOR
THEY REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. THE BILL CLARIFIES
THAT UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT THAT IF
YOU ARE UNDER THE AGE OF
THIRTEEN YEARS OLD. YOU NEED
PARENTAL CONSENT BEFORE
STARTING A SOCIAL MEDIA
ACCOUNT. NOW I KNOW THERE ARE
THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
IF YOU'RE TWELVE OR ELEVEN OR
TEN. AND YOU'RE IN A DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCE AT HOME AND YOU
WANT TO GO ON THE INTERNET TO
FIND. SOME COMMUNITY OR SOME
PLACE THAT GIVES YOU SOME
COMFORT FOR RESOURCES THAT
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT RESOURCE
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO HAVE BUT I
DID WANT TO CLARIFY THAT. THAT
RESOURCES LIKE THE TREVOR
PROJECT WHICH IS CRITICAL FOR
LGBT YOUTH CURRENTLY DOES HAVE
A REQUIREMENT SHOULD BE
THIRTEEN OR OVER TO UTILIZE
THEIR SOCIAL MEDIA FRAMEWORK TO
REACH OUT BUT I KNOW THERE ARE
OPINIONS ON ON OTHER SIDES OF
THIS ISSUE AND I WELCOME THEM.
BUT IN MY JUDGMENT I THINK IN
IN THE JUDGMENT OF THIS
LEGISLATION TWELVE. OR UNDER IS
SIMPLY TOO YOUNG TO JUST GO
ONLINE AND TRY TO FIND YOURSELF
WITHOUT ANY PARENTAL OVERSIGHT.
THERE ARE MANY DANGERS ON THE
INTERNET WELL IS INCREDIBLY
USEFUL TOOL WE THINK THAT THOSE
MINERS OUGHT TO HAVE AT LEAST
SOME PARENTAL CONSENT. WITHOUT
A RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT. YOU
CONSIDER STERN. NUMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE WIENER.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT ON HIGH I RISE
RESPECTFULLY AND STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL BECAUSE
I THINK THIS LEGISLATION WILL
CAUSE SEVERE HARM TO LGBT USE I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT I
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE AUTHOR OF
THIS LEGISLATION IS TRYING TO
DO. I UNDERSTAND THAT THE THERE
ARE NO BAD MOTIVES HERE THE
AUTHOR IS TRYING TO PROTECT
CHILDREN BECAUSE THERE ARE
RISKS FOR CHILDREN TO GO ONLINE
AT A YOUNG AGE SO THIS IS NOT
ABOUT CASTING ASPERSIONS ON
MOTIVES OR ANYTHING ELSE WHAT
I'M FOCUSED ON IS WHAT THE
ACTUAL EFFECT OF THIS BILL.
WILL BE. THIS BILL WILL HARM
LGBT USE WHO ARE IN ABUSIVE
HOMES WITH PARENTS WHO NOT ONLY
DON'T SUPPORT THEM. BUT OUR
AFFIRMATIVELY I'VE BEING
INCREDIBLY NEGATIVE TOWARDS AND
HARMING THEM AND ISOLATING THEM
AND TELLING THEM THAT THEY ARE
WORTHLESS. THESE KIDS WITHOUT
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET. OR
QUICKLY CUT OFF FROM ANY HOPE
OF UNDERSTANDING. THAT THERE IS
HOPE FOR THEM AND THAT THERE
ARE PEOPLE LIKE THEM IN THE
WORLD THESE KIDS BECOME TRAPPED
IN THEIR HOMES. THERE ARE MANY
PARENTS WHO ARE WONDERFUL AND
ACCEPTING AN AFFIRMING ABILITY
TO YOU. BUT EVEN TODAY TWENTY
NINETEEN THERE ARE SO MANY LGBT
KIDS WHO WERE TRAPPED IN
ABUSIVE HOMES. THIS BILL WILL
RESULT IN MORE SOLATION OF
THESE KIDS AND MORE HARM TO
THESE KIDS. LGBT YOUTH ARE
AMONG THE MOST VULNERABLE
PEOPLE IN OUR SOCIETY. TOO MANY
HAVE ON SUPPORT EVER ABUSIVE
PARENTS THAT ARE HARMING THEM
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE PARENTS
WHO STILL SEND THEIR KIDS TO
CONVERSION THERAPY WHICH AS WE
KNOW IS PSYCHOLOGICAL TORTURE
IN FACT THIS LEGISLATURE BANDS
CONVERSION THERAPY OR NEWS.
THESE PARENTS ARE TELLING THEIR
CHILDREN THAT THEY'RE WORTHLESS
THAT THEY ARE SICK WITH THEIR
BROKEN BUT THEY ARE AN
EMBARRASSMENT. THE DAY ARE
HUMAN REFUSE THAT'S WHAT THESE
KIDS ARE HEARING FROM THESE
PARENTS THIS IS THE REALITY
THAT FAR TOO MANY LGBT YOUTH
CONTINUE TO FACE IN THEIR OWN
HOMES IT IS REAL. AN ALL TOO
MANY OF THESE KIDS WHEN THEY GO
TO SCHOOL IT IS NO BETTER THEY
ARE GETTING BULLIED AND
HARASSED. THEY HAVE ALL FAR TOO
OFTEN TEACHERS AND STAFF WHO
DON'T INTERVENE WHO DON'T HELP
THEM AND MAY ACTUALLY MAKE THE
SITUATION WORSE. HI THERE THE
STATISTICS ARE ALARMING. 67% OF
LGBT YOUTH REPORT THAT THEY
HAVE HEARD FAMILY MEMBERS MAKE
NEGATIVE COMMENTS ABOUT LGBT
PEOPLE. LGBT YOU SERIOUSLY
CONTEMPLATE SUICIDE AT ALMOST
THREE TIMES THE RATE OF NINE
LGBT YOUTH. LGBT YOUTH ARE
ALMOST FIVE TIMES AS LIKELY TO
HAVE ATTEMPTED SUICIDE COMPARED
TO NINE LGBT YOUTH. LGBT YOUTH
WHO COME FROM HIGHLY REJECTING
FAMILIES ARE OVER EIGHT TIMES
AS LIKELY TO HAVE ATTEMPTED
SUICIDE AS LGBT YOUTH WHO HAVE
SUPPORTIVE FAMILIES. MORE THAN
HALF OF TRANSGENDER MALE TEENS
REPORT HAVING ATTEMPTED SUICIDE
IN THEIR LIFETIME WELL 30% OF
TRANSGENDER FEMALE TEENS REPORT
THE SAME. AMONG NON BINARY USE
41% ATTEMPTED SUICIDE AT SOME
POINT IN THEIR LIVES. SO WHAT
DOES THAT HAVE TO DO WITH THIS
BILL. FOR MANY OF THESE YOU THE
ONLY SUPPORT THAT THEY HAVE THE
ONLY WAY THAT THEY HAVE
CONNECTING WITH THEIR COMMUNITY.
IS THROUGH THE INTERNET THAT IS
A. THAT IS HOW BIG DEBTS
SUPPORT IT'S HOW THEY CAN
CONNECT WITH OTHER PEOPLE LIKE
THEM IT IS HOW HEY THEY CAN
LEARN THAT IT GETS BETTER THAT
IF THEY JUST HANG ON TO LIFE
AND A SAYS STAYS STRONG AND
PERSEVERE IT WILL GET BETTER
FOR THEM AND THERE ARE PEOPLE
OUT THERE WHO SUPPORT THEM AND
LOVE THEM AND FOSTER THEM. I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE RISKS
FOR CHILDREN ON THE INTERNET
BUT I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
IN THIS CONVERSATION THAT WE
HAVE A COMPLETE CONVERSATION
THAT THESE KIDS WILL BE HARMED
BY THIS LEGISLATION AND I WILL
BE VOTING NO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR WIENER SENATOR
PORCHES. MADAM PRESIDENT. AS A
FATHER OF TWO YOUNG BOYS.
SOMETIMES I FEEL OLD FASHIONED
BY SAYING THIS BUT I AM SHOCKED
AT WHAT IS AVAILABLE ON THE
INTERNET. AND WHEN ONE OF MY
BOYS YOU KNOW GETS A HOLD OF MY
WIFE'S PHONE WHICH HAPPENS
QUITE OFTEN BECAUSE THEY'RE
CLEVER AND GET THE CODE TO
ACCESS THE PHONE EVEN THOUGH
CHANGES I THINK. THERE NEEDS TO
BE SOME SORT OF SAFETY MEASURE
PUT INTO PLACE AND I THINK THIS
MAY NOT BE PERFECT AND I KNOW
THAT MY FRIEND FROM SAN
FRANCISCO BRINGS UP SOME SOME
GOOD POINTS ON CERTAIN
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. THAT FIND
THIS TYPE OF COMMUNITY OUT
REACH ARE HELPFUL TO THEIR
PARTICULAR CIRCUMSTANCE. BUT AS
AS A WHOLE I THINK HAVING THE
SAFETY MEASURES IN PLACE I
ULTIMATELY ALLOW THE PARENTS TO
REGAIN SOME CONTROL NOT UNLIKE
THE CODES THAT. I THINK IT'S
HELPFUL IT'S NOT GONNA BE
PERFECT MAYBE THEIR WAYS TO
MAKE IT BETTER MOVING FORWARD
BUT I'LL CERTAINLY BE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS TODAY. SENATOR
BOARD JUST SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AS I
AS I LISTEN TO US I REALIZE
THAT WE'RE WE'RE SOUND AND MIKE
THE. OLD PEOPLE THAT WE CLEARLY
ARE. IN THAT WE ARE USING
TERMINOLOGY INTERCHANGEABLY AND
WE SHOULDN'T. THERE'S THE
INTERNET AND THEN THERE SOCIAL
MEDIA. TWO SEPARATE THINGS. SO
YES OUR CHILDREN PICK UP OUR
PHONES AND CAN SURF THE WEB AND
SEE THINGS THAT'S TRUE. I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
IS ADDRESSING. AND SO OUR
QUESTION OF THE FOR JACKIE IF I
MAY MATTER PRESIDENT. YEAH
THERE ARE CERTAINLY TO THE
QUESTION YES PLEASE PROCEED IF
YOU COULD CLARIFY THAT THE
FOCUS OF THIS BILL. IS LIMITING
A MINER'S ACCESS TO
ESTABLISHING THEIR OWN SOCIAL
MEDIA PRESENCE OR IS IT
LIMITING ACCESS TO THE INTERNET
NO IT WOULD STRICTLY BE LIMITED
TO JUST ESTABLISHING A SOCIAL
MEDIA ACCOUNT NOT ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET. THANK YOU SO YOU KNOW
THE REALITY IS EVEN WITH
COMCAST IN THE PARENTAL
CONTROLS ALL OF YOUR CHILDREN
CAN NAVIGATE AROUND THAT TRUST
ME. THEY ARE ALL SMARTER THAN
WE ARE PERIOD THEY KNOW THE
COLDS YOU PICK THEIR BIRTHDAYS
YOUR OWN BIRTHDAYS YOUR HOUSE
ADDRESS THEY KNOW IT. WE CAN
NOT UNDER ESTIMATE THE POWER
AND THE DANGER. OF. SOCIAL
MEDIA EXPOSURE. THE I THINK A
NUMBER OF THE SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES ATTEMPTED TO SET UP.
AGE RESTRICTIONS BEFORE IN ALL
THE KIDS HAD TO DO WAS JUST A
LIE ABOUT THEIR BIRTH YEAR IT
REALLY WASN'T HARD. AND SO WE
ARE FOR EVER PLAYING CATCH UP
WITH TECHNOLOGY WE ARE PLAYING
CATCH UP. AND WE'RE PLAYING
CATCH UP WITH ARE YOU THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES. AND YET AND STILL
WE CANNOT UNDERESTIMATE THE
POWER OF SOCIAL MEDIA
PARTICULARLY WHEN OUR CHILDREN
ARE VULNERABLE. AND THEY'RE
REACHING OUT THROUGH THAT
MEDIUM LOOKING FOR VALIDATION
AND PEOPLE TO HEAR THEM. WE AS
PARENTS IN THE ADULT IN THE
WORLD SHOULD SHOULD FEEL SOME
KINDA WAY THAT WE HAVE CREATED
A SITUATION IN WHICH THAT'S THE
ONLY OUTLET A YOUNG PERSON
HANDS WHETHER WE SUPPORTER
BELIEVE IN THEIR LIFE CHOICE
AND NOT. GONNA THAT THEY HAVE
FOUND THEMSELVES IN A SITUATION
THAT THAT'S THE ONLY PLACE THEY
CAN GO TO. I REALLY STRUGGLE
WITH THIS BILL. BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND THE POWER AND THE
DANGERS OF SOCIAL MEDIA I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THE POWER IN ITS
ABILITY TO HELP PEOPLE IDENTIFY
WITH LIKE MINDED INDIVIDUALS
FIND SUPPORT AND FIND THEIR OWN
VOICE I REALLY STRUGGLE. I
THINK HOWEVER I'M GOING TO HAVE
TO MAKE A DECISION TODAY THAT
REFLECTS. WHAT'S IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF ALL CHILDREN GIVEN.
THE AGE RESTRICTION I GOES HERE
THAT THERE IS A MATURITY LEVEL
THAT ALL CHILDREN HAVE. AND
THAT WE AS ADULTS HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO PUT BRACES IN
PLACE TO PROTECT THEM SOMETIMES
FROM THEMSELVES UNTIL THEY
REACH THE AGE OF MATURITY AND
CAN HANDLE WHAT'S OUT THERE IN
THE WORLD. I THINK THAT WE
AGAIN SHOULD REALLY BE CLEAR
ABOUT WHAT ROLE WE HAVE PLAYED
AND WHAT LACK OF SUPPORTS
PERHAPS WE ARE NOT MAKING
AVAILABLE AT SCHOOL. IN THE
HOME AND OTHER SETTINGS WHERE
CHILDREN WHO ARE VULNERABLE ARE
IN BAD SITUATIONS AT HOME HAVE
NO PLACE ELSE TO GO TO FOR
SUPPORT THAT'S ON US AND WE
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO
BETTER. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL CENTER DOLLY. THE BAND
PRESENT MEMBERS I. THERE'S A
ONE OF THOSE BILLS THAT IS AS A
PARENT SASANA SHARE A LITTLE
BIT AS MANY YOU KNOW WE HAVE
TWO SONS WHO ARE OLDER.
NINETEEN AND SEVENTEEN AND THEN
WE HAVE ROSLYN WHO IS NINE.
WILL BE TEN NEXT MONTH. AND WE
HAD A POLICY IN OUR HOME THAT
NO CELLPHONES INTEL THIRTEEN.
THAT WAS OUR POLICY WELL I HATE
TO TELL YOU BUT RAZA HAS A
PHONE. AND SHE'S NINE. SHE RUNS
THE HOUSE AS YOU ALL KNOW. BUT
WHAT IS READ THROUGH FOR ME I
HAVE COMPASSION AND I HEARD MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO'S
COMMENTS. AND YOU KNOW THERE'S
A GOOD AT THEIR EXACTLY WHAT TO.
THE SENATOR FROM EL áREA
TALKED ABOUT IS THAT YOUR
PARENTING IS A BIG PART OF THIS
AND BEING PART OF YOUR
CHILDREN'S LIVES AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE GONNA FIND ALL KIND OF
THE REASON WE CHOSE TO GIVE OUR
DAUGHTER OF PHONE IS BECAUSE
THE STUFF THAT SHE WAS SEEING
ON OTHER PHONES AT SCHOOL. AND
SO WE CAN HELP COMMUNICATE WITH
HER AND ALSO MONITOR WHAT IS
GOING ON THROUGH THE OTHER
PHONE. ON FACEBOOK AND LIKES SO
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
THERE MAY BE SOME AVENUES TO
TIGHTEN THIS UP UNDER OTHER
LEGISLATION BUT I THINK THERE'S
GONNA BE A LOT OF HELP THIS
THIS WILL HELP A LOT OF PARENTS
AND GIVE THEM SOME TOOLS TO.
HELP BE MORE INVOLVED IN THEIR
CHILDREN'S LIVES THROUGH SOCIAL
MEDIA. AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS
ALL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY SENATOR
NIELSEN. MADAM PRESIDENT LEGEND
GENTLEMAN THE SENATE WELL I AM
AGAIN SYMPATHETIC TO OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO'S
CONCERNS AND I CERTAINLY
STIPULATE THERE ARE BAD PARENTS.
BUT FOR MANY YEARS. GOVERNMENT
AS INTERFERED WITH THE PARENT
CHILD RELATIONSHIP. MADE IT
HARDER. FOR PARENTS TO BE
ENGAGED IN THE LIVES OF THEIR
CHILDREN. THEN CAME THE
INTERNET INVADING OUR HOMES
WITH MUCH GOOD. BUT ALSO SOME
REALLY BAD. PARTICULARLY THE
SEXUAL PREDATORS I PERFECTED
THIS MEANS OF GROOMING VICTIMS.
YOU READ ABOUT ALL THE TIME.
AND IT WILL ONLY INCREASE. BY
DOING THIS WE ARE TAKING AN
ATTEMPT. DESTRUCTIVE THE
FAMILIAL BOND. THE MOTHER. AND
THE FATHER. A VERY YOUNG CHILD
A VERY IMPRESSIONABLE CHILD.
AND THOUGH THERE ARE
DIFFICULTIES WITH. PERRANCE. I
SUBMIT THAT THE BLOOD BOND. THE
MOTHER AND FATHER. IS A
SUPERIOR BOND TO ALL AND WE
MUST PROTECT THAT BOND THIS
BILL. IS A GOOD STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION I REGION I VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I DO WHOLEHEARTEDLY
AGREE WITH THE COMMENTS WERE UP
WITH THE GREAT CENTERED ON LOS
ANGELES THAT DONNA WE DO KNOW
THAT SOCIAL MEDIA IS POWERFUL
BUT THERE IT'S ALSO VERY VERY
DANGEROUS AND I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO IT
IS YOU KNOW THEY'RE EXTREMELY
VALID POINTS HOWEVER. IT IS A
REAL THREAT TO OUR CHILDREN AND
I CAN JUST TELL YOU VERY
BRIEFLY SOME A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
HOW IT'S OUT OF OUR HANDS IN
THE EDUCATIONAL WORLD THAT I
COME FROM WE HAD A COMMUNITY OF
ABOUT TEN KIDS SCHERING NAKED
PHOTOS ALMOST NAKED PHOTOS OF
THEMSELVES ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND
IT TOOK US A LITTLE WHILE TO
CATCH ON TO IT. MY POINT BEING
IS I'M NOT SURE THEY'RE MATURE
ENOUGH TO UNDERSTAND THE
DIGITAL FOOTPRINT TEN IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO BE
THERE FOREVER I THINK AS
ELECTED OFFICIALS WE UNDERSTAND
ONE PICTURE OUT THERE YOU'LL
NEVER GET IT BACK AND STILL WIN
FAIR EXPOSING THEMSELVES AT
NINE. THEY DON'T KNOW HOW THAT
MAY AFFECT THEM THIRTY YEARS
FROM NOW AS THEY'RE SEEKING A
JOB THEY'RE SEEKING EMPLOYMENT
AND NOW AS WE KNOW NOW MENTORS
ARE ARE USING SOCIAL MEDIA TO
UNDERSTAND. THE PERSON THAT
THEY'RE HIRING AND MANY HAVE
BEEN DENIED EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE
OF SOME OF THE BEHAVIORS ON
SOCIAL MEDIA AND I THINK THAT
EVEN WHEN WE GO TO THIS THEATER
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A AND P. G.
THIRTEEN FOR RESENT OUT BECAUSE
WE NEED PARENTS MONITORING THAT
KIND OF CONTENT AND SETTLE AS
MUCH AS I DO UNDERSTAND YOU
KNOW THE SUPPORT SYSTEM THAT TO
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO SPOKE OF. I THINK AT
THIS TIME UNTIL WE CAN FIGURE
OUT OTHER SAFEGUARDS IT SIMPLE
AND FOR US TO BE THE MONITORS.
AND BIRDS OF OUR YOUTH AND SO
WITH THAT. HI JUST WANTED TO
SHARE NOT TO. SAY YES OR NO BUT
REALLY JUST WANTED TO SHARE THE
REAL THREATS TO OUR CHILDREN
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO CENTER
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU AND THIS IS
BEEN A GREAT DISCUSSION AND I
WOULD JUST SAY AS A PARENT OF
THREE BOYS. EIGHTEEN TWELVE FOR
WHO ARE ALL IN SOCIAL MEDIA
WILL NOT ANSWER ME ON THE
INTERNET. I WOULD CERTAINLY BE
EXCITED TO WELCOME YOU KNOW MY-
MY KIDS IN IN ENGAGING AND
WEBSITES THAT ARE THAT ARE GOOD
FOR THEM BUT I KNOW THAT ALL
PARENTS ARE NOT THE SAME. I'M
ALSO VERY OPEN AND WELCOMING AS
WELL SO I KNOW THAT IF MY CHILD
HAPPEN TO BE L. G. B. T. I'D BE
HAPPY ABOUT THAT. BUT NOT A LOT
OF PARENTS ARE LIKE ME. AND TO
YOUR POINT OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND AND I TAKE THAT OF
FULL YOU KNOW TO HEART. I ALSO
KNOW THAT TERE'S YOUNG WOMEN
OUT THERE THAT COULD ALSO HAVE
THE POTENTIAL BE LIMITED A
BECAUSE HE MAY BE SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED AT HOME AND THERE
COULD BE A MULTITUDE OF VARIOUS
ISSUES. SOME VERY. I UNDERSTAND
COMPLETELY WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
WHAT I WOULD HOPE THAT THIS
BILL WOULD DO IF IT IS
IMPLEMENTED AND I AM GOING TO
BE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS. IS THAT
IT WORKS WITH OUR- LGBT Q.
CENTERS ARE SEXUAL ASSAULT
CENTERS TO EDUCATE YOUNG ADULTS
SO THAT THEY UNDERSTAND FULLY
WHAT THEY'RE GETTING INTO ON
THE INTERNET AND SOCIAL MEDIA.
ALSO HAVING WORKED AT MICROSOFT
FOR MANY YEARS I ACTUALLY
ENGAGED IN A LOT OF. WORK NOT
JUST WITH PARENTS BUT WITH
YOUNG STUDENTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY KNEW EXACTLY WHAT
THEY WERE GETTING GETTING INTO
IF THEY DID CREATE AN ACCOUNT.
AND WE JUST DON'T WANT TO GO
DOWN A RABBIT HOLE OF ALLOWING
THESE. THESE YOUNG STUDENTS
THESE YOUNG ADULTS TO BE ABLE
TO ACCESS A SOCIAL MEDIA
ACCOUNT THAT THEY MAY NOT KNOW
HOW TO ACT TO OPERATE. AND SO
FOR THAT REASON I WILL BE IN
SUPPORT. BUT I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE SAYING I
REALLY DO HOPE THAT WE WORK
WITH THE CENTERS TO ENSURE THAT
YOU KNOW STUDENTS AND KIDS ARE
USING THEM APPROPRIATELY. AND
THAT WE CAN YOU KNOW GORE FOR
GO FORWARD FROM THERE SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER GONZALEZ
SENATOR DRAWS SO. I THINK WAT
IS MOST TROUBLING TO ME IS
THAT. WE'RE TALKING HERE ABOUT
WHETHER TO PROTECT. THIS GROUP.
OR THAT GROUP MEAN IT FEELS
LIKE. THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG
WITH THAT THE CONVERSATION. WE
ALL CARE ABOUT ALL THESE KIDS
ESPECIALLY THE MOST VULNERABLE.
AND I FEEL AS IF WE'RE NOT EVEN
CATCHING UP. THOSE WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALLOWING THIS
IN THE FIRST PLACE ALLOWING IT
TO BE ON OUR DIFFERENT SOCIAL
MEDIA OR INTERNET WHICH I
DON'T. TECHNICALLY UNDERSTAND.
BUT WE GOT TO GET TO THE ROOT
OF THE ISSUE MORE THAN WHICH IS
MORE VALUABLE WHICH OF OUR KIDS
WHICH ARE WE GOING TO PROTECT
MORE THAN OTHERS THAT JUST
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE AS A LAW AND
THE I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THAT BUT I THINK THAT THOSE WHO
ARE THE TECHIES WHO DO
UNDERSTAND THIS WE HAVE TO GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF NOT ALLOWING
THIS TO BE. ANY KIND OF DANGER
FOR ANY OF OUR KIDS FOR ALL OF
OUR KIDS AND I CERTAINLY HOPE
WE CAN DO THAT BECAUSE I THINK
WERE TAKING THESE MEASURES MUCH
LIKE I FELT WHEN THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT HOMELESS STUDENTS SHOULD
PARK WHO WERE LIVING IN THEIR
CARS SHOULD PARK IN THE PARKING
LOTS OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THAT IS NOT AN ANSWER TO THE
PROBLEM SO. I'M ALSO VERY TORN
BUT I'M EVEN MORE TORN BECAUSE
AN ANGRY THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH IT ON THIS LEVEL RATHER
THAN ON THE TRUTH GET TO THE
CAUSE OF THE PROBLEM LEVEL.
THANK YOU SENATOR TO RUSSELL
SENATE JACKSON IS A VERY
BRIEFLY I WANT TO ADDRESS THE
POINT BY MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
LOS ANGELES. SO AS WE READ
THINGS THAT ARE GOING ON
NATIONALLY AS WE LEARN WHAT
COMPANIES LIKE FACEBOOK. ARE
DOING THEY ARE THE DRIVERS
HERE. WE ARE TRYING TO REPAIR
THE CONCERNS THE DAMAGE THE
UNDERMINING OF WHAT WE THINK
THE SOCIAL FABRIC OF OUR
SOCIETY BOTH LOOKS LIKE AN
SHOULD LOOK LIKE SO I WOULD
JUST URGE US ALL GOING FORWARD.
WE ARE HERE. ACTING UP. A
SYSTEM THAT IS IN GREAT NEED OF
BEING REVIEWED. CHALLENGED
BROUGHT NOT ONLY TO THE TABLE
BUT BROUGHT TO ACCOUNTABILITY
WHICH WE ARE STARTING TO SEE
HAPPENING. EUROPE OF COURSE
HAS. BEEN THE PENALIZE SOME OF
THESE COMPANIES WE KNOW THAT
THEY HAVE NOT ALWAYS BEEN
FORTHCOMING THIS IS A MUCH
LARGER DISCUSSION THAT WE NEED
TO HAVE IT'S IMPERATIVE BECAUSE
THE INMATES ARE REALLY RUNNING
THE ASYLUM AND WE NEED TO GET
BACK. SOME CONTROL ON BEHALF F
OUR COMMUNITIES AND AS YOU
MENTIONED PARTICULARLY ON
BEHALF OF OUR CHILDREN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE THUNDERSTORMS BUT TO
CLOSE YES THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. WHAT A THOUGHTFUL
DEBATE. ON THIS ISSUE I THANK
ALL MY COLLEAGUES FOR WEIGHING
IN YOU KNOW I DON'T COME TO
THIS BILL WITH THE PERSPECTIVE
OF PARENT. BUT RATHER. YEAH
HOPEFULLY SOMEDAY SOON. BUT I
HAVEN'T EVEN GOTTEN MARRIED YET.
BUT I COME IN IS IT IS SOMEBODY
CAME OF AGE WITH FACEBOOK MY
FRESHMAN YEAR IN COLLEGE WE HAD
A BOOK WITH FACES IN IT THAT WE
CIRCLED THE FACES AND LOOKED AT
WHO IS GOING TO BE IN CLASS
THAT DAY AND THEN SOPHOMORE
YEAR. SO MANY MARK ZUCKERBERG
CAME TO SCHOOL AND DECIDE TO
PUT ALL THAT ON THE INTERNET.
AND HERE WE ARE. A FEW YEARS
LATER AND THE ENTIRE WORLD IS
CHANGED. THE ENTIRE NATURE OF A
OF WHAT A OF FRIENDSHIP NETWORK
LOOKS LIKE IT'S CHANGED HOW WE
INTERACT WITH EACH OTHER IS
CHANGED. HOW WE SIT AT THE
DINNER TABLE IS CHANGED HOW
YOUNG PEOPLE TREAT EACH OTHER
IN IN ELEMENTARY AND JUNIOR
HIGH AND HIGH SCHOOL IS
CHANGING. AND THEY MAY SAY
THAT. IT'S JUST A PLATFORM. BUT
IT'S JUST TO A NEUTRAL PIPELINE
OF INFORMATION. BUT I THINK TO
THE CENTER FROM SANTA BARBARA.
AND SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES IS
POINT. IT'S TIME THAT THE TECH
INDUSTRY TOOK AN EQUITY STAKE.
IN THE EXTERNAL COSTS OF THE
PRODUCTS THAT WE UTILIZE THERE
IS GREAT VALUE TO THESE
PRODUCTS YES BUT THERE ARE
GREAT COST AS WELL. SO I THINK
IF YOU'RE SUPPORTING HIS BILL
TODAY WHICH I CERTAINLY WILL BE.
YOU'VE ALSO BOUND YOURSELF IN
MY VIEW TO A COMMITMENT. TO TRY
TO FIND SOME WAY. TO OFFSET
THESE EXTERNAL COSTS ON OUR
YOUTH AND I THINK THAT. THE
TECH INDUSTRY OUGHT TO BE
TAKING A. EQUITY STAKE IN MORE
LGBT CENTERS AND MORE ARE MORE
RESOURCES FOR AT RISK YOUTH OF
ALL GENDERS SEXUAL ORIENTATIONS
RACES. BECAUSE IT'S HAVING AN
IMPACT ACROSS THE BOARD. AND
THAT GOES AS WELL FOR THE
IMPACT ON JOURNALISM. AND OTHER
EXTERNAL COSTS THIS IS NOT A
NEUTRAL INDUSTRY THEY CAN BE
LEADERS BUT IT'S TIME THAT WE
PUT A COMPREHENSIVE FRAMEWORK
TOGETHER NOT JUST PROTECT
PRIVACY. BUT TO ADDRESS THESE
UNDERLYING EXTERNAL COSTS. THE
LAST THING I WOULD JUST SAY IS.
YOU KNOW I RESPECTED THE FAMILY
BOND IS CRITICAL AND THAT
PARENTS I'M I'M BLESSED TO HAVE
GROWN UP IN A HOME WHERE. I WAS
LOOK LOVE PROBABLY TOO MUCH BUT
BUT LOOKED AFTER AND I DIDN'T
HAVE TO FIND IN THIS STATE.
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE FOR AND
REAL NEGATIVE REINFORCEMENT.
BUT I YOU KNOW I WATCHED IN MY
FAMILY MY TEENAGE SISTERS GO
THROUGH SOME VERY HARD TIMES
AND THE OUTLET THAT THEY FOUND.
ON SOCIAL MEDIA WAS VERY
IMPORTANT TO THEM. BUT I
REMEMBER VERY VIVIDLY REAL
RISKS THAT EMERGED AND I DON'T
WANT TO GET INTO TOO MUCH
DETAIL BUT- YOU HAVE TO MAKE A
JUDGMENT CALL WHETHER. AT THE
AGE OF TWELVE OR UNDER
UTILIZING A RESOURCE. IS MORE
PERILOUS THAN IT IS PRODUCTIVE.
I THINK THAT PARENTS CAN'T BE
RELIED ON SOLELY THAT WE NEED
THESE EXTERNAL RESOURCES SO
WHEN I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY I'M ASKING FOR A
COMMITMENT INTO NEXT YEAR AND
ESPECIALLY WORKING WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO IN
THOSE OF US WHO DO WORK WITH
THE TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY TO SAY
WHAT IS IT LOOK LIKE WHEN THEY
STEP UP AND COME TO THE TABLE
AND ACTUALLY ACCOUNT FOR THE
COSTS. THE EXTERNALITIES
THEY'RE IMPOSING ON US AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK. THANK
YOU CENTER STERN MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
BATES HI BILL NO. GORGEOUS HI
BRADFORD HI CAMBIADO I CHIANG I
DALY I DODD HI DORADO AYE
GALGIANI. GLAZER GONZALEZ HI
GROWTH HI HERTZBERG. HILL BY
HUESO I TADO. JACKSON I JONES I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. MITCHELL
MONNING. BY MORE LOCK TIME RAIL
BY NELSON I PAN. BY PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH. BY RUBIO BY SKINNER.
SKINNER NO. STERN. STERN AYE
STONE I AM BURKE. I Y. CASKEY.
NO WIENER NO WILK HI. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN I
ATKINS. GALGIANI. GLAZER BY
HERTZBERG TADO HI MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL. I THIRTY ONE KNOWS
FOR THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WE ARE NOW GOING TO GO TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS SO IF
YOU HAVE A COMMITTEE MEETING
PLEASE LET US KNOW AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO RECESS FOR LUNCH
FOR ONE HOUR SALUTE THOSE
COMMITTEES CAN MEET AND YOU CAN
EAT. SENATOR GLAZER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. WILL MEET
TEN MINUTES UPON RECESS SO. TEN
MINUTES FROM NOW IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE HERE A SINGLE
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU CENTER GLAZER MEMBERS ANY
OTHER COMEDIAN ELSE WHAT
SENATOR HUESO. YES MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATE ENERGY
UTILITIES TO COMMUNICATIONS
COMMITTEE. WILL MEET DURING THE
BREAK ROOM AND THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE UPON A GERMAN OF
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS ABOUT
VERY GOOD ON A GERMAN OF
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS THANK
YOU SIR. SENATOR ALAN. I THE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE
WILL BE MEETING AFTER THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE IS THAT
CORRECT MR. ENERGIZER BUNNY.
AFTER IN THE I'M SORRY AFTER
THIS AFTER THE ENERGY COMMITTEE.
AFTER THE ENERGY COMMITTEE IN
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE THANK YOU
SIR MADAM PRO TEM THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT TO MY
COLLEAGUES I AT AS WE RECESS
FOR LUNCH I WOULD INVITE ANYONE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO STAY ON THE
FLOOR FOR A MOMENT TO TAKE A
PHOTOGRAPH. WITH THE SECRETARY
CHIEF CLERK THANK YOU OF THE
ASSEMBLY DOTSON WILSON A NUMBER
OF US ACTUALLY SERVED WITH HIM
THOSE OF US THAT SERVED IN THE
ASSEMBLY BEFORE WE CAME TO THE
SENATE BUT I WOULD INVITE
ANYONE. THAT WOULD LIKE TO JOIN
US FOR A QUICK PHOTOGRAPH IN A
RESOLUTION THAT WE I HAVE
PRESENTED HIM THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM PRO TEM MEMBERS WILL
BE ON RECESS UNTIL ONE O'CLOCK.
PLEASE BE BACK ON THE FLOOR AT
ONE O'CLOCK
. MEMBERS THE- WE
WILL RECONVENE AT RECESS WILL
BE OVER IN THIRTY SECONDS
.
WELCOME BACK MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO PICK UP WHERE WE LEFT
OFF WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE SENATOR
MCGUIRE. I DO NOT SEE HIM IN
ANYONE'S DESK. OF FILE ITEM
SIXTY ONE SENATOR HUESO. FILE
ITEM SIXTY TWO ALSO SENATOR
MCGUIRE. FILE ITEM SIXTY FIVE
SENATOR HERTZBERG ARE YOU IN
THE CHAMBERS NO FILE ITEM SIXTY
SIX SENATOR DODD. ALL RIGHT
LET'S GO BACK TO FILE ITEM
WHERE WE STARTED THIS MORNING
FITS FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT
SENATOR TO RISE SO. FILE ITEM
FORTY FOUR SENATOR GONZALEZ
WOULD YOU TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
FORTY FOUR. HOUSE ON FILE FILE
ITEM FORTY FIVE IS ALSO SENATOR
MCGUIRE SO WE ARE IN NEED OF
SOME AUTHORS
. MEMBERS WE'RE
GONNA START WITH FILE ITEM
SIXTY ONE WHICH IS SENATOR
HUESO MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. A SOME OF THE ONE SEVENTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES AN ACT RELATING TO
ALTERNATIVE ENERGY TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY
SENATE HUESO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AB ONE SEVENTY SIX
UPDATES THE SALE AND USE TAX
EXCLUSION PROGRAM. BY EXPANDING
THE VALUATION CREEK CRITERIA
FROM NEW PERMANENT JOBS TO NEW
FULL TIME PERMANENT JOBS AND
ALSO ADDRESSES THE POTENTIAL
LOSS OF FULL TIME PERMANENT
JOBS AND THE AVERAGE AND
MINIMUM WAGE RATES BY JOB
CLASSIFICATION OF FULL TIME
EMPLOYEES PROPOSED TO BE HIRED
OR NOT RETAINED. AS CALIFORNIA
CAN TRANSITIONS TO IN A LOW
CARBON FUEL ECONOMY IT'S DOUBLY
IMPORTANT THAT THE STATE
INCENTIVIZE IS SUPPORT AND
SUPPORTS. QUALITY JOBS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ON AB ONE SEVEN SIX THANK
YOU SENATOR. HUESO MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. BY ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BILL BY BURGESS.
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO CHIANG.
DALY I DODD. HI THERE ALSO. I
GALGIANI. BY GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH. HERTZBERG
HILL. I WITH SO HI TADO. BY
JACKSON. JONES HI LEYVA MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL HI MONNING. BY MORE
LOCK I AM A REAL. NIELSEN AYE
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO SKINNER. STERN. HI HI
STONE AYE AMBERG BARBER CASSIE
BY WIENER. WILK. HI SENATOR
MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WERE GOING
TO MOVE A FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX
SENATOR DODD WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TAKE A FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO AN ACT
RELATING TO CONSUMER PRIVACY
SENATOR DODD BETTER PRESENT
MEMBERS AB TWENTY FIVE
CLARIFIES THAT THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THAT'S THE
CCP A EXCLUDES UNTIL JANUARY
FIRST TWO TWENTY TWENTY ONE
INDIVIDUALS WHOSE PERSONAL
INFORMATION HAS BEEN COLLECTED
BY BUSINESS WITHIN THE SCOPE OF
THEIR EMPLOYMENT OR IS SIMILAR
SIMILARLY. IT SITUATED CONTACTS
BUT ONLY TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
INFORMATION IS COLLECTED AND
USED SOLELY FOR THE PURPOSE
RELATED TO THOSE ACTIVITIES
MANY BUSINESSES OF ARGUED THAT
THE CCPA COULD BE READ TO APPLY
TO CALIFORNIANS IN THEIR
CAPACITY AS EMPLOYEES OR IN
SIMILARLY SITUATED CONTEXT THE
CAPTURE THEIR EMPLOYEE DATA.
WHILE WE NEVER ENVISIONED THIS
BEING AN ISSUE IT HAS BEEN
EXPRESSED THAT AS DRAFTED AN
EMPLOYEE ACCUSED OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT COULD REQUEST THE
COMPLAINTS ABOUT THEM BE
EXPUNGED FROM COMPANY FILES
THIS CLARIFICATION INSTEAD
SHOULD WOULD ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS RETAIN THEIR RIGHTS
UNDER THE CCPA IN THEIR
CAPACITY AS A CONSUMER BUT NOT
WITHIN THE SCOPE OF THEIR
EMPLOYMENT OR IN SIMILAR.
LAURIE SITUATED CONTACTS. HE'S
HOWEVER WILL STILL RETAIN
PROTECTION TO THE DATA BREACH
INCIDENTS IN THEIR RIGHT TO
KNOW CATEGORIES OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION BEING COLLECTED BY
A BUSINESS AND THE PURPOSE FOR
WHICH THEY ARE USED. ANOTHER
ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN RAISED IS
THE CONCERN THAT HIGHLY
SENSITIVE INFORMATION COULD
FALL INTO THE WRONG HANDS WHEN
A REQUEST IS MADE FOR SPECIFIC.
PIECES OF INFORMATION THE
BUSINESS COLLECTED ABOUT
CONSUMER. PART OF THE SOLUTION
IS TO MAKE PERMISSIBLE FOR
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE ACCOUNTS
WITH CONSUMERS TO REQUIRE
CONSUMERS THE USE THIS TABLET
CHECKOUT TO EXERCISE THEIR CCPA
RIGHTS DOING SO HELPS PREVENT
THEM. FROM PROVIDING PERSONAL
INFORMATION TO THE WRONG
INDIVIDUAL AND THEREBY
PROTECTING PRIVACY RESPECTFULLY
ASK DR. THANK YOU SENATOR. DODD
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. BY ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BILL I
PURCHASED. BRADFORD I CABALLERO
I CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD AYE
DORADO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG.
HILL AYE HUESO HI TADO I
JACKSON JONES I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE. MITCHELL. BY MONEY I'M
MORE LOCK I'M A REAL AYE
NIELSEN AYE PAN. I PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO SKINNER I
STERN. I STONE. I AMBERG OUR
COUNTY I WIENER. WILK HI HI
SENATOR MOVES A CALL. MEMBERS
OF AN ASK YOU TO HANG TIGHT WE
DO HAVE A FEW MORE BILLS TO
TAKE UP WITH THE AUTHORS ARE
NOT ON THE FLOOR SO WE WILL BE
LOOKING FOR THEM
. MEMBERS WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR AUTHORS LET'S
MOVE TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THIS WOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME TO MOVE ITEMS
TO THE INACTIVE FILE. SENATOR
ARCHULETA. DID YOU HAVE A BILL
YOU WANT TO MOVE TO THE
INACTIVE FILE YES MADAM
PRESIDENT I'D LIKE TO MOVE ITEM
FIFTY FIVE A. B. TWO FORTY.
PASS ON FILE WITH THAT AND MOVE
OF MOVED TO INACTIVE. THANK YOU
SENATOR ARCHULETA THE DESK WILL
NOTE ANYTHING ELSE UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SENATE. SENATOR RUBIO FOR
WHAT PURPOSE YOU RISE UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS PROCEED
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE A BEFORE SIXTY
FIVE EGGMAN FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
THE DESK WILL NOTE THANK YOU
.
HERTZBERG WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT FILE ITEM SIXTY FIVE
WONDERFUL MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ FILE ITEM SIXTY
FIVE. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
FIFTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAO AN ACT GOING TO CONSUME
FOR PRIVACY. SENATOR HERTZBERG
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF. MADAM
PRESIDENT IN ADDITION TO THE
BRIEFLY TALK ABOUT THE
AMENDMENTS PURGED GIVEN WITH
MORE CONTEXT FOR THIS BECAUSE
OF ITS IMPORTANT NATURE IF YOU
RECALL AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THIS IN A FEW MEASURES ON THE
FLOOR LAST SESSION THIS BODY
ENACTED THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
PRIVACY ACT WHICH GRANTED ALL
CONSUMERS THE RIGHT TO REQUEST
FROM A BUSINESS THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION IT COLLECTS
OURSELVES ABOUT THEM ITS
PURPOSE FOR DOING SO AND WITH
WHOM THE PERSONAL INFORMATION
IS SHARED. THIS MEASURE IS THE
RESULT OF EXTENSIVE
NEGOTIATIONS AMONG US MY CO
AUTHOR FROM THE GREAT PART OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA NAPA
TOGETHER WITH OUR JUDICIARY
CHAIR AND IT DOES THE FOLLOWING
MAKES THE FOLLOWING THREE
CLARIFYING BUT IN THE A COMPORT
CHANGES TO THE C. C. P. A THE
BILL CLARIFIES THE DEFINITION
OF PERSONAL INFORMATION. THE
BILL ADDRESSES INCONSISTENCY
BETWEEN THE CCPA AND THE FAIR
CREDIT REPORTING ACT AND
INSURERS COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN
BUSINESSES THAT ARE PROVIDING
SERVICES TO EACH OTHER ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO THE C. CPA THERE ARE
COMMONSENSE FIXES I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG MEMBERS DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
BELL FIVE LARGEST. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO BY CHAIN AYE DALY AYE
DODD I DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ BY GROVE.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI TADO I JACKSON JONES I LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE. MITCHELL. HI
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK I'M A
REAL. I NIELSEN I PAN. I
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. HI RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
AYE AMBERG POWER CASKEY I
WIENER. WILK HI FI SENATOR
MOVES A CALL
. MEMBERS WE'RE
GONNA GO BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS SENATOR TO ROSS SO.
YES MADAM CHAIR. AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR I'D LIKE TO MOVE
ITEM THIRTY EIGHT A. B. FOR
EIGHTEEN TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
THANK YOU CENTER DRAWS SO THE
DESK WILL NOTE. MINING FOR
PURPOSE TO RISE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. I HAVE A LETTER TO
THE JOURNAL ARISE TO REQUEST
PERMISSION TO SUBMIT THIS
LETTER TO THE SENATE JOURNAL
CLARIFYING THE INTENT OF SENATE
BILL TWO HUNDRED IT HAS BEEN
REVIEWED AND APPROVED BY BOTH
SIDES. AND I URGE YOUR
ACCEPTANCE THANK WITH WITHOUT
OBJECTION THANK YOU SENATOR
MONNING. SENATOR JACKSON YES
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR I
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE FILE ITEM
SIXTY AB EIGHT FORTY SIX TO THE
INACTIVE FILE THE USER JACKSON
THE DESK WILL NOTE
. MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY
SENATOR GALGIANI. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARK STONE
ECHOING TO FOOD NET CULTURE AND
MAKE IN PREPARATION THEREFORE.
CENTER GALGIANI THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS BILL
CREATES A CALIFORNIA DUNGENESS
CRAB COMMISSION TO PROMOTE THE
MARKETING AND PRODUCTION OF THE
DUNGEON AS CRAB. IT GOT THROUGH
OUR AG COMMITTEE WITH ALL AYE
VOTES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
GALGIANI. YEAH MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS AYE BATES.
HI BILL I BRIDGES. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO BY CHIANG AYE DALY
AYE DODD. I DORADO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GREW.
I HERTZBERG. HI HILL AYE HUESO
HIGHER TADO. I JACKSON. JONES
JACKSON AYE JONES BY LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE. MITCHELL MITCHELL I.
MONEY I'M MORE LOCK. MORRELL
NIELSEN. I PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE. I AM BURKE
OUR CASKEY I WINNER BY WILK HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
PORGES BY. MCGUIRE. BY MORE
LUCK BY MERRELL HI. EYES FORTY
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
SUTTER BORCHERS FOR WHAT
PURPOSE YOU RISE AND PRESENT IF
I COULD TO MAKE A FRIENDLY
INQUIRY INTO THE CONDITION THE
FILE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
RECOGNIZING JULIE SALT WHO IS
MY CHIEF OF STAFF AND TODAY IS
HER BIRTHDAY. EARLY WHERE
YOU'RE THAT'S ACTUALLY.
LITERALLY SHE SAW IT COMING.
THAT'S ACTUALLY PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR SORRY BUT WE WISH HER
THE MOST HAPPIEST OF BIRTHDAYS
THANK YOU. THIRD REQUIRE ARE
YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM FIFTY NINE. FROM HIS OWN
DESK MIRACLES NEVER SEES.
MISTER SERETARY PLEASE READ
FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTY TWENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER AN ACT
RELATING TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. SENATE MCGUIRE THANK
YOU SO MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT AND
I ALSO. THROUGH YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT WOULD ALSO BE
PRIVILEGE TO BE A TAKE A FIVE
SIXTY TWO YOUR TO YOUR
CONVENIENCE AS WELL. UNDER TO
BE ABLE TO PRESENT AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN WHICH WOULD CHANGE
COUNTY REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
CREW DEVELOPMENT COLLEGE
PREPARATION NON CREDIT COURSES.
A DEFINITIVE INDEED ARE FUNDED
PER FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
STUDENTS BASED ON A SPECIFIC
DATE LIKE OTHER CREDIT COURSES
UNDER CURRENT LAW NON CREDIT
COURSES NON CREDIT COURSES AS
WELL AS CAREER DEVELOPMENT IN
COLLEGE PREPARATION COURTS
COURSES SUCH AS- ENGLISH AS A
SECOND LANGUAGE FORCES. AUTO
SHOP COURSES AT COLLEGES
LEARNING HOW TO BE ABLE TO BE
TYPISTS OR CLERK ARE DIFFERENT
ATTENDANCE IS TAKEN MANAGING
ROMAN COURSES WHICH HAVE
IDENTIFIED A DEFINITIVE START
IN INDIA TO BECOME MORE THE
NORM FOR CAREER DEVELOPMENT IN
COLLEGE PREPARATION NON CREDIT
COURSES. AS THEY SHOWN T BE A
TO INCREASE STUDENT RETENTION
SUCCESS AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN WOULD BETTER EQUALIZE
FUNDING FOR NON CREDIT COURSES
THAT ARE OFFERED WITH THE START
AND END DATE RATHER THAN BASING
ON ONGOING ATTENDANCE. WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THIS BILLS HAD NO
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU CENTER
CHOIR MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE AYE
AYES FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES SOON REQUIRE YOU ARE
PREPARED FOR A TO PRESENT FILE
ITEM SIXTY TWO. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING. SENATE
MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO MUCH
BETTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF
PLEASE READ PRESENTED ONBEHALF
OF THIS AND THE WOMAN WEEKS TO
BE FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIVE IT'S
CAN ENSURE TIMELY APPROVAL. OF
COMPLETE. OF COMPLAINT HOUSING
PROJECTS THROUGH MINISTERIALIS
STREAMLINED REVIEW PROCESS FOR
MIXED INCOME OR MISSING MIDDLE
DEVELOPMENTS WITHIN THE NINE
BAY AREA SAN FRANCISCO
COUNTIES. THE BILL IS CRUCIAL
TO ACCELERATE MAKES INCOME
HOUSING PRODUCTION AND WILL
HELP KEEP AT CALIFORNIANS HOUSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER MCGUIRE
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
THERE IS OBJECTION MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI. ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. HI BILL I BRIDGES HI
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO. CHIANG
I DALY. I DODD. I DORADO HI
GALGIANI I GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
GROW. HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE
HUESO. HI FOR TITLE BY JACKSON.
I JONES BY LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
AYE MITCHELL HI MONNING I'M
MORE LOCK. I'M A REAL I NIELSEN.
I PAN BY PORTANTINO I ROTH BY
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE AYE AMBERG. BY KELSEY I
WIENER AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. CAPPIELLO
BY GLAZER. BY GROWTH BY AMBERG.
BY WILK HI. WELL AYE AYES FORTY
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
.
SENATOR MITCHELL FOR WHAT
PURPOSE. OKAY POPS. SENATOR
GROW FOR WHAT PURPOSE TO RISE
FOR ANNOUNCEMENTS MADAM
PRESLEY'S PROCEED AND LIKE TO
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER EVAN LOW
FOR BRINGING MCKINNEY'S
APPETIZERS AND SEE SEAT INTO
THE LOUNGE BECAUSE HE WAS
CONCERNS ABOUT HIS SAID IT
OCCURS SENATORS BEING ANGRY.
WELL WE THANK HIM VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. SENATOR MITCHELL FOR
WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RISE. I'D
LIKE TO PRESENT ON FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE. ONE MOMENT
AND THEN WE WILL START
. THIS IS
FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SIX ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
FOURTEEN BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND ACT
RULING TO EDUCATION FINANCE
MAKING PURPOSE THEREFORE TAKE
EFFECT MERELY BILL RELATED BUT-
SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A META PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES OF THE NEXT SEVERAL
MEASURES THAT I'LL BE TAKING UP
ON BEHALF OF THE SENATE BUDGET
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE. OUR
TRAILER BILLS THAT WERE VOTED
ON TWO DAYS AGO BY THE FULL
BUDGET COMMITTEE THE FIRST ITEM
WE'RE TAKING UP AS ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE FOURTEEN WHICH IS THE
EDUCATION CLEAN UP TRAILER. IT
CONTAINS STATUTORY CHANGES TO
IMPLEMENT THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT. THE BILL DOES THE
FOLLOWING AN APPROPRIATE THAT
ADDITIONAL FIFTY SEVEN POINT
THREE MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
PURPOSES OF ONE TIME CHILD CARE
INVESTMENTS. COMBINED WITH
ADJUSTMENTS IN THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR THIS RESULT IN A NET
ZERO IMPACT THE CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS THE SHIPS THE LINE
FUNDING FOR CHILDCARE PROGRAMS
WITH ALLOWABLE USES OF FEDERAL
FUNDS. IT EXTENDS THE ETHNIC
STUDIES MODEL CURRICULUM
DEADLINE FOR SUBMISSION BY THE
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMISSION TO DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY. AND THE
DEADLINE FOR ADOPTION BY THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION TO
MARCH THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. IT DEMANDS THE
CALIFORNIA KIDS INVESTMENT IN
DEVELOPMENTAL SAVINGS PROGRAM
TO ALLOW ALL CHILDREN BORN
AFTER JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
TO BE ELIGIBLE THE MIX OF OUR
IT MAKES A VARIETY OF OTHER
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS AND I ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEN
SELECT DELL AND I WOULD URGE A
NO VOTE AT THIS POINT IN TIME
THIS THIS LEGISLATION I BELIEVE
IS STILL EVOLVING WE REALLY
DON'T KNOW WHEN THERE'S
CONTROVERSIAL PORTIONS IN IT
JUST A QUESTION THANK YOU
CENTER NIELSEN SENATOR MITCHELL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I WOULD
JUST CLARIFY I THINK THE GOOD
SENATOR RAISE SOME QUESTIONS
AND CONCERNS IN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE RUN THE ETHNIC
STUDIES MODEL CURRICULUM THIS
BILL MERELY EXTENDS THE
DEADLINE IF THERE ARE MEMBERS
WHO ARE INTERESTED AND WANT TO
ENGAGE IN THE CONTENT OF THE
CURRICULUM DISCUSSION WE
CERTAINLY IS ELECTED OFFICIALS
CAN FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO SO
AND- AND WORK. WITH THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION WHO HAS THE
POWER TO FOR YOU TO DO SO AGAIN
THIS BILL MERELY EXPANDS THE
DEADLINE BY WHICH THE NEW
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMISSION WILL HAVE DEVELOPED
THE CURRICULUM I THINK THIS
BILL IN THIS. IS A COMPLETE
DOCUMENT AGAIN IT IS THE BILL
CLEAN UP TO BUDGET BILL TWENTY
NINETEEN AND BASED ON THAT I'M
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR MITCHELL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BY
BATES NOBEL BY PORGES NO
BRADFORD I CABALLERO HI JANE.
NO DALY NO DODD I DORADO I
GALGIANI. GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE. HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO AYE OR TADO. JACKSON. I
JONES NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING. BY MORE
LOCK NO MORALE NO NIELSEN NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. ROTH. HI
RUBIO AYE SKINNER. HI STERN BY
STONE NOVEMBER IOWA CASKEY I
WIENER BY WILK HI. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS GALGIANI.
GROVE NO PORTENT GALGIANI AYE
PORTANTINO AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
WELL IT CERTAINLY IS ICE THIRTY
KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
SEVEN SENATOR MITCHELL. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SOME OF
THE ONE FIFTEEN BY THIS
IMMIGRANT ON BUDGET AND
ACTUALLY MEDI CAL MAKING
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL REALLY
DID BUDGET. TELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
AB ONE FIFTEEN IS THE MANAGED
CARE ORGANIZATION ALSO KNOWN AS
THE MCO TAX BILL. IT EXTENDS
THE M. SEAL TAX WHICH EXPIRED
ON JULY FIRST TWENTY NINETEEN
FOR AN ADDITIONAL THREE AND A
HALF YEARS. TO THE PREVIOUS MCL
TAX THE NEW TAXES THE TIERED
ENROLLMENT BASED TAX AND WILL
BE ASSESSED ON MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATIONS LICENSED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE. AND CONTRACTED TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES. THE REVENUE FROM
THE TAX WILL BE CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO
SUPPORT THE NON FEDERAL SHARE
OF EXPENDITURES IN THE MEDI CAL
PROGRAM. THE ADMINISTRATION
ESTIMATES THE TAX WILL RESULT
IN NET REVENUE OF ONE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWO POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AND ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE FIRST
SIX MONTHS IF TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. THESE RESIDENT THESE
REVENUES ARE THE RESULT OF THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO DRIVE DOWN
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS WHICH
PROVIDES DURABLE RECESSION
PROOF FINANCIAL STABILITY TO
THE MEDICARE PROGRAM WHICH
SERVES THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS. I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL SENATOR NIELSEN.
CALPERS LAYS DOWN THE SENATE I
DO ARGENEAU VOTE HERE THIS IS
C. N. M. C. O. TAX WE'VE HEARD
LOTS OF DISCUSSIONS ABOUT IT
THERE HAVE BEEN CONCERNS ABOUT
IT. IT DOES GIVE THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH AND HEALTH CARE
SERVICES A OPPORTUNITY TO RAISE
OF THIS TAX DURING THE THREE
YEARS AND I WOULD. THEREFORE
THINK WE SHOULD VOTE NO ON THIS
PLUS THE GENERAL FUND IS
HEALTHY NOW. AND I BELIEVE THAT
WE WOULD NOT NEED THIS EXTRA
TAX MONEY. THANK YOU CENTER
NIELSEN CENTER MITCHELL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ABSOLUTELY.
YES THE GENERAL FUND IS HEALTHY
AND IT'S OUR COLLECTIVE
RESPONSIBILITY TO KEEP IT THAT
WAY. IN THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
THIS PAST WEEK WE HEARD SUPPORT
FOR THIS. BUILT BY
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE HEALTH
PLAN ORGANIZATIONS I'M SURE
MANY OF YOU LIKE I DID RECEIVE
LETTERS FROM THERE IS HEALTH
PLANS. THAT WILL BE SUBJECT TO
THIS TAX WHO. WE'RE VERY CLEAR
ABOUT WHY THEY SUPPORTED IT WHY
THEY FELT IT WAS FAIR THE NEW
ALGORITHM THAT WAS DEVELOPED.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS IS THERE
IS NO. THERE MAY HAVE BEEN SOME
OPPOSITION BUT NOT FROM THOSE
WHO ARE REQUIRED TO PAY INTO
THE INFIELD TAX. I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
NO BILL I PORGES. NO BRADFORD.
HI CAMBIADO I CHIANG NO DALY NO
DODD I DORADO AYE GALGIANI. HI
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW NO
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO.
TADA WITH SO I OR TITLE. HI
JACKSON BY JONES NO LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL. HI MONEY
BY MORE LOCK. NO MORRELL NO
NIELSEN. PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH BY RUBIO AYE SKINNER I
STERN BY STONE NO BURKE IRA
CASKEY BY WINNER BY WILK. NO
PLEASE CALL THE OF THE MEMBER
NIELSEN NO. I TWENTY NINE KNOWS
ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES. YES
PRESIDENTIAL I'D LIKE TO
REQUEST IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL
OF FILE ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN AB
ONE FIFTEEN AND FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SIX AS WELL PLEASE
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
ASSEMBLY THE DESK WILL NOTE
THANK YOU. FILE ITEM SEVENTY
EIGHT MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
EIGHTEEN BY THE ASSEMBLY CAMINO
BUDGET AND ACTING STATE
EMPLOYMENT MAKING PROGRESS IN
THERE FOR TO TAKE EFFECT MERELY
BILL REALLY TO THE BUD.
SENATOR MITCHELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
EIGHTEEN AGAIN AND OTHER BUDGET
TRAILER BILL THAT WAS HEARD IN
FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE THIS
WEEK. THIS FOCUSES ON A
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING.
THE TRAILER BILL THAT WOULD
RATIFY THE IMHO USED BETWEEN
THE STATE AND THIRTEEN STATE
BARGAINING UNITS. AND WHAT
IMPACT APPROXIMATELY ONE
HUNDRED NINETEEN THOUSAND.
STATE EMPLOYEES. THESE
BARGAINING UNITS ARE
REPRESENTED BY SEIU LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND. CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES AND
HEARING OFFICERS AND STATE
EMPLOYMENT. THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL ASSOCIATION. THE
CALIFORNIA STATE WIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION. AND
THE INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS. WHILE THE
MO USE REFLECT THE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT EACH
BARGAINING UNIT. FROM COMMON
ADJUSTMENTS INCLUDE THE
FOLLOWING. GENERAL SALARY
INCREASES WITHIN THE RANGE OF
3% EACH YEAR AND ADDITIONAL PAY
FOR SPECIFIED CLASSIFICATIONS
OR PURPOSES. GEOGRAPHIC PAY
DIFFERENTIAL FOR EMPLOYEES WHO
WORK IN HIGH COST REGIONS OF
THE STATE. AND PRE FUNDING
PENSION BENEFITS AND RETIREE
HEALTH BENEFITS I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR NIELSEN. THAT A
PRESERVATION JAIL IN THE SENATE
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN MY
PREFERENCE TO DIVIDE THE
QUESTION ON THIS OR HAVE
SEPARATE VOTES ON THE DIFFERENT
AMMO USE. THAT IT DOES NOT
APPEAR TO US IN THAT SEPARATED
FORM AND I AM INFORMED BY LEAD
COUNSEL THAT WE CANNOT MAKE A
MOTION HERE TO. DIVIDE THE
QUESTION. THAT SAYS THEN WE
HAVE TO VOTE ON THE ENTIRE LIST.
AND OUR CAUCUS HAS SOME
PROBLEMS WITH SOME OF THESE
SOME WERE. SUPPOSED TO BE VERY
SUPPORTIVE UP. IN SOME THERE
ARE BUT WHAT I WOULD CONSIDER
VERY FAIR CONCESSIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE BY BOTH SIDES THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE-
BARGAINING UNITS. IN OTHERS NOT
SO MUCH SO. THAT TOTALLY SAID
WE'RE VOTING ON A WHOLE LIST
HERE AND I WOULD BE
RECOMMENDING THAT TO EITHER OF
STAYING OR VOTE NO. THANK YOU
CENTER NIELSEN CENTER MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. THE
JOYS OF TRYING TO BALANCE A
BUDGET AND TRYING TO. RESTORE
BALANCE SHEET IS AS A FUN TASK.
ALSO THE JOYS OF HAVING A
DEFINED BENEFIT PENSION PLAN.
MAKES THE MATH EVEN MORE
INTERESTING SO BETTER PRESENT
I'M I'M HAVING DIFFICULTY
GIVING RAISES WHILE WE STILL
HAVE PENSION PLANS THAT ARE
FUNDED AT THE 70% RANGE. IT'S
IT THE OTHER PRIVATE SECTOR
DOESN'T SEE. A STRONG GENEROUS
DEFINED BENEFIT PENSION PLAN.
AND RAISES SO FOR THAT REASON I
AM GOING TO BE OPPOSED TO AB
ONE ONE EIGHT THANK YOU MADAM%
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SENATOR
MORLOCK FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
MANSON WHICH WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I WOULD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT MEMBERS ARE CLEAR ABOUT
SPECIFICALLY WHICH BARGAINING
UNITS ON THIS TRAIN THE BILL
COVERS. BARGAINING UNIT ONE
THESE ARE ALL UNDER SEIU LOCAL
ONE THOUSAND. ADMINISTRATIVE
FINANCIAL STAFF SERVICES
BARGAINING UNIT THREE
PROFESSIONAL EDUCATORS AND
LIBRARIANS BARGAINING UNIT FOR
OFFICE AN ALLIED BARGAINING
UNIT ELEVEN ENGINEERING AND
SCIENTIFIC TECHNICIANS
BARGAINING UNIT FOURTEEN THE
PRINTING TRADES BARGAINING UNIT
FIFTEEN THE ALLIED SERVICES.
BARGAINING UNIT SEVENTEEN
REGISTERED NURSES BARGAINING
UNIT TWENTY MEDICAL AND SOCIAL
SERVICES. IN UNIT TWENTY ONE
EDUCATION CONSULTANTS AND
LIBRARY IMPORT PLEASE AGAIN IT
ALSO INCLUDES CASE THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES AND
HEARING OFFICERS AND STATE
EMPLOYMENT. THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HIGHWAY
PATROLMAN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
WIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSOCIATION AND THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS ALL REMIND
ALL MY COLLEAGUES OF THE SINGLE
SUBJECT RULED THAT PERTAINS TO
TRAILER BILLS. AND I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE IN AB ONE EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES. BELL FIVE
LARGEST. BRADFORD I HAVE A
YELLOW I CHIANG I DALY NO DODD.
HYDRO SO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO. TADO I
JACKSON. JACKSON AYE JONES.
LEYVA HI TIME ACQUIRE. BY
MITCHELL HI MONNING BY MORE
LOCK NO MORALE. NIELSEN. PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO. SKINNER HI STERN BY.
STONE. NUMBER OF A COUNTY BY
WIENER AYE WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BATES.
GORGEOUS BORDERS NO BATES.
GROWTH. HI WITH SO I. JONES
MERRELL NIELSEN RUBIO HI. STONE.
I THIRTY TWO KNOWS THREE THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO FILE
ITEM SEVENTY NINE SENATOR
MITCHELL MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
TWENTY ONE BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND ACT
WILLING TO SOCIAL SERVICES AND
MAKING PROGRESS THERE FOR TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY THE
RELATED BUDGET. CENTER MITCHELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT ANOTHER SINGLE
SUBJECT TRAILER BILL AB ONE
TWENTY ONE THE CLEAN UP BUDGET.
TRAILER BILL FOR HUMAN SERVICES.
VISIONS IN THIS BILL MAKE
TECHNICAL AND CLEAR FINE
CHANGES RELATED TO THE CAL
WORKS PROGRAM. SPECIFICALLY THE
BILL CLARIFIES WHAT SPECIFIC
INFORMATION SHOULD BE INCLUDED
IN NOTICES RELATED TO CHILD
CARE AND CLEAR FIVE PROVISIONS
RELATING TO THE CAL WORKS OVER
PAYMENT SYSTEM I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR NIELSEN. BUT A
PRESIDENTIAL SENATOR THIS IS A
FAIRLY BIG TICKET ITEM DEAL
DEALS WITH A VERY IMPORTANT
PROGRAM I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH
THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM THERE'S
SOME DECENT. IN THIS AND
THERE'S SOME BAD TOO WE'RE
STILL TAKE RING WITH A PROGRAM
THAT USED TO WORK VERY VERY
WELL AND- IT CAME UP ON HARD
TIMES AND NOW SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE ORIGINALLY
REJECTED IN THE- ORIGINAL BILL.
I MEAN RITUAL LEGISLATION WHICH
GOES BACK INTO THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES TO HAVE BEEN SEVERED
FROM THE PROGRAM. IT'S STILL
GENERALLY A GOOD PROGRAM BUT IT
IS NOT WORTHY OF THE YES VOTE
HERE TODAY. THANK YOU CENTER
NIELSEN. THEN WHICH WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. I WOULD TO
REMIND US ALL THAT THE CAL
WORKS PROGRAM IS THE PROGRAM
THAT REQUIRES THAT LOW INCOME
WORKING PARENTS WERE TO BE TO
KEEP THEIR CHILDREN OUT OF
POVERTY. DO WORK GO TO SCHOOL
ENGAGE IN SOME KIND OF
ACTIVITY. ARE CAL WORKS PROGRAM
CALIFORNIA IS TIME LIMITED. AND
THE ELEMENT THAT'S INCLUDED IN
THIS TREE RUBIO FOCUSES ON
TWELVE MONTHS CONTINUOUS
ELIGIBILITY FOR CHILD CARE TO
MAKE SURE THOSE WHO ARE TRYING
THEIR BEST TO GO TO WORK AND
GET A- EDUCATION TO PROVIDE FOR
THEIR FAMILIES. HOW THE CHILD
CARE THEY NEED IN ORDER TO DO
THAT THAT'S THE CONTENT OF THIS
TRAILER BILL. AS A RESULT I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. L. HI GORGEOUS
BRADFORD I CABALLERO BY CHIANG
I DALY DODD I DORADO I GALGIANI.
HI GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ HI GROW.
HERTZBERG. HI HILL AYE HUESO
TADO HI JACKSON. HI JONES.
JONES LEYVA TIME ACQUIRE. BY
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK. MORRELL NIELSEN. PAN BY
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
NUMBER. WHAT COUNTY I'M I'M A
GUY WHAT CASKEY AYE WIENER. HI
WILK BY. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BATES BY. YES NO DALY.
GROWTH. HUESO HI JONES. MORE
LOCK. MERRELL NIELSEN. STONE NO.
I THIRTY TWO DOES TO THE
MEASURE PASSES MADAM PRESIDENT
IF I MAY PUT FORGIVE ME I
FORGOT ONCE AGAIN TO REQUEST
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL OF FILE
ITEM SEVENTY NINE AND FILE ITEM
SEVENTY EIGHT TO THE ASSEMBLY
AND SO JUST TO CLARIFY I'M
ASKING FOR IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL OF ALL OF THE
BUDGET TRAILER BILL THAT I'VE
JUST PRESIDENT THIS AFTERNOON
TO THE ASSEMBLY. TWO ARE
ALREADY THERE AND TWO WERE ON
THEIR WAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU'RE MITCHELL. MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING BACK TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS TO FILE ITEM ELEVEN
SENATOR MITCH EXCUSE ME CENTER
JACKSON. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL FIVE
FIFTY ONE BY SENATOR JACKSON AN
ACRYLATE OIL AND GAS CYLINDER
JACKSON THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES THIS IS A
BILL THAT DIRECTS THE- DIVISION
OF OIL GAS AND GEOTHERMAL
RESOURCES. KNOWN AS DARKER AND
HOPEFULLY A NAME TO CHANGE SOON.
THE REX THEY RECEIVE REPORTS
FROM ALL OIL AND GAS OPERATORS
AT LEAST ONCE EVERY FIVE YEARS
THE PROVIDE FINANCIAL
ASSESSMENTS AS TO THE FULL COST
OF DECOMMISSIONING AND
REMEDIATING THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
FOR PRODUCTION OF OIL AND GAS
THE BILL WAS AMENDED IN THE
ASSEMBLY TO FULLY SPELL OUT THE
REPORTING PROCESS. WHICH THANKS
TO CHANGE WITH EXPERTS IN
INCLUDED DISCUSSIONSWITH
INDUSTRY ITSELF IT CURRENTLY
HAS NO REGISTERED OPPOSITION.
AND IT IS A GOOD MIDDLE OF THE
ROAD APPROACH TO ENSURE LOCAL
AND STATE OFFICIALS NO FULLY
THE POTENTIAL COST OF
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THEIR
DISTRICTS WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND CONCURRENCE IN
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU
SENATOR JACKSON MEMBER ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE. MOMENT. THIS
ONE MAKE SURE IT IS NOT A
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI OUR SHIP IN A AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES NOBEL I
BRIDGES NO BRADFORD. HI
CABALLERO I CHIANG. NO DALY NO
DODD AYE TERRAZZO AYE GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ BY
GROVE. NO HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO BY HER TITLE I
JACKSON BY JONES. NO LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING BY MORE LOCK. NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. BY STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER OUR CASKEY I WINNER.
BY WILK. NO FIVE TWENTY NINE
THOSE ELEVEN THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS WE HAVE FIVE ITEMS ON
CALL WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL ON THOSE ITEMS
. MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM THIRTY THREE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD. HI
JANE. JONES MONEY. JONES NO
MONNING BY. CHIANG NO. ICE
TWENTY NINE DOES ELEVEN THE
ASSEMBLY MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN SIR THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG
MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES BELL
BY BURGESS. CHIANG DELHI. GROVE
HERTZBERG BY MORE LOCK. NIELSEN
SKINNER. BY WILK. ICE TWENTY
NINE THOSE THREE THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING TO FILE ITEM
SIXTY ONE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GORGEOUS
CABALLERO. CHANGE CAREER CHIANG
FORGES CAREER I WERE JUST AYE
CHIANG AYE GROWTH. I HERTZBERG
I JACKSON BY MCGUIRE. I AM A
REAL BY RUBIO AYE SKINNER. FIVE
WINNER HI. EYES FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO
FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BURGESS HI
GROWTH. I HERTZBERG. BY JACKSON
BY MCGUIRE I RUBIO. BY WINNER.
AYE AYES FORTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO FILE
ITEM SIXTY FIVE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES. BURGESS
BY GROWTH. JACKSON. PROVIDE
JACKSON AYE MCGUIRE BY WIENER.
WIENER AYE BATES AYE. EYES
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. FOR THOSE ARE THE
MEMBERS THOSE ARE ALL OF THE
BILLS THAT WE HAVE A CALL
SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR WHAT
PURPOSE YOU RISE. OUR ROOM BACK
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
SENATOR GALGIANI. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I'D LIKE TO REQUEST
A RECONSIDERATION OF ITEM FORTY
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO.
MEASURE MODE BUT MEMBERS THERE
IS A MOTION TO RECONSIDER. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION A
RECONSIDERATION. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE RECONSIDERATION IS
GRANTED AYE AYES FORTY KNOWS
ZERO. CENTER GALGIANI I'D LIKE
TO REQUEST TO MOVE THE BILL TO
THE INACTIVE FILE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. THE DESK WILL NOTE
THANK YOU. SIR WIENER DID YOU
HAVE SOME ITEMS THAT YOU WANTED
TO MOVE. PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AT THE
REQUEST OF THE OFFER AUTHOR I
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE
FOLLOWING THREE BILLS TO AN
ACTIVE NUMBER ONE AB. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY THREE. BY ADAM BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY. NUMBER TWO
AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY SIX BY THE
ASSEMBLY GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE NUMBER
THREE AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
BY THE ASSEMBLY GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU CENTER WINNER THE DESK WILL
NOTE MEMBERS RON MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS ANYONE ELSE HAVE
ANYTHING THEY WANT TO MOVE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THANK
YOU. COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH BETTER PRESENT WE
HAVE ONE BILL IN GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCES AFTERNOON WITH THAT
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE TO BE
ABLE TO MEET AT FOUR PM IN
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE FOUR PM.
IN THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. SO
NOTED THANK YOU CENTER MCGUIRE
ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. OKAY SEEING AND
HEARING THEM THANK YOU. MADAM
PRO TEM THE DESK IS CLEAR THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. HI WOOD
THE- FIRST LIKE TO CALL A
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS AT THE AS WE
ADJOURN UPON ADJOURNMENT AND
COLLEAGUES WE WILL WORK.
RECONVENE TOMORROW FRIDAY
SEPTEMBER THIRTEENTH AT TEN
THIRTY AM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM. WHATEVER SENATOR
GROW FOR PURPOSE TO RICE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS MADAM
PRESIDENT IN THE COX LOUNGE.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROWTH. THE
SENATE WILL BE ADJOURNED WE
WILL RECONVENE TOMORROW FRIDAY
AT TEN THIRTY AM